foreign
in this week's episode we'll talk about
the most popular and commonly used
programming language python so let's
begin and learn about the development of
python and gain insights about the
current ID Trends but before that make
sure to subscribe to our Channel and hit
the Bell icon to get notified every time
we come up with new content python is
very famous for its simple programming
syntax core readability and English like
commands that make coding a lot easier
and efficient due to this it is the most
popular and preferred language python
has interpreted high-level general
purpose programming language developed
by Guido van rossim at National Research
Institute for mathematics and computer
science Netherlands in contrast to
popular belief that python was named
after this week python was actually
named after the show Monty Python's
Flying Circus
Guido van Rossum formulated python in
the late 1980s as a successor to the ABC
language in 1994 python version 1.0 was
released with features like exception
handling Lambda map filter and reduce
python 2.0 released in 2000 introduced
features like list comprehensions and a
garbage collection system capable of
collecting reference Cycles python 3.0
was released on the 3rd of December
2008. undoubtedly Python 2.x and 3.x
have proven to be the most used versions
as of today python 3.7.4 is the latest
stable version released in the summer of
2019. python is popularly used for
development scripting and software
testing top ID companies like Google
Facebook Instagram Spotify and Netflix
among others use Python some major
applications of python can be seen in
the fields of machine learning
artificial intelligence data science and
iot python also offers many libraries
like numpy sci-fi Keras tensorflow
Django and flask pep 8 is the official
style guide that defines the styling
conventions for python code a few
popular open source python projects
include EnV statistics solving the
traveling salesman problem using
self-organizing math and python to BPF
converter some of the trending python
repositories on GitHub today include NLP
ml from scratch pytorch Transformers 100
days of ml code among others popular
websites on the internet like Reddit and
quora are built using python
civilization 4 Battlefield 2 Sims 4 and
World of Tanks are some popular games
developed using python according to
indeed the average salary of a python
developer in India is about 5 lakhs per
annum and that in the US is around 124
000 US Dollars users and admirers of
python especially those considered
knowledgeable are referred to as
pythonous pythony stars and pythonians
since its Inception python has come a
long way to become the most popular
coding language and continues to
revolutionize the IT industry so here is
the agenda for the session
first we will go through the quick intro
to python then we will understand who
exactly a python developer is after that
we will go through the skill set of a
python developer the job roles that are
suitable for python developers the
current salary trends of a python
developer in the tech industry and in
the end we will have a look at the
resume of a python developer to get
insights into real world credibility and
employability of a python developer
so without further Ado let's get started
introduction to python so let's quickly
go through this very concise python
intro python is an interpreted
high-level interactive object-oriented
scripting language
python is very versatile in nature and
therefore its applications are spread to
various fields in the industries more
popularly in web development machine
learning and Ai and game development
so who is a python developer let's
answer this so here are some of the
Technologies used by a python developer
pandas Anaconda tensorflow python Ides
Django web framework and patreon a
python developer is one Who develops
backend components of a web application
using python when working as a web
developer now the web Frameworks like
Django and flask are used for this
purpose
a python developer is also the one who
writes effective testable and scalable
python code he also performs data
analysis when working in the field of
data science so basically a python
developer develops deploys debugs and
maintains a project so let's go through
the skill set of a python developer now
the core python skills that a python
developer possesses are data structures
like arrays list stack queues trees and
graphs there's oop Concepts like
inheritance classes and objects and
abstraction thus packages and functions
that is importing external packages into
a python code database and its
connection that is connecting a python
backend to a database like MySQL when it
comes to data science skills there's
numpy that is a library for performing
mathematical calculations
let's pandas that is the library for
storing and manipulating data
efficiently this SCI pi and then there's
matplotlib which is a library for
plotting charts and graphs for a given
data and finally there are machine
learning algorithms which consists of
models like supervised learning
unsupervised Etc now coming to web
developer skills there are Frameworks
like Django and flask for back-end
development of web applications
and then there's web scraping which
includes taking data from websites and
converting that data into usable format
there's API handling which is basically
handling API requests for a web
application to perform server-side
operations and finally there is back-end
connection which basically involves the
backend part of a web application and is
usually handled by python Frameworks
now moving on let's look at the python
developer job roles
first up is python web developer now a
python web developer usually writes
server-side code works on the web
Frameworks like Django and flask
collaborates with the data team to
gather end users requirements develops
the server-side platform deploys
applications performs tuning usability
Improvement and automation
moving on next job role is data analyst
now a data analyst generally works on
python libraries including matplotlip
numpy pandas Etc carry out data analysis
collect data using the scripting
language explore data sets gather
requirements tune in applications
analyze problems communicate findings
with the team or stakeholders
the next job role is automation test
engineer
now an automation test engineer usually
works on python test framework tools
including Pi test Pi unit perform
complex system tests troubleshoot code
issues create test scripts design the
automation framework perform a b testing
next up is machine learning engineer
now a machine learning engineer has the
following roles to perform statistical
analysis of data put machine learning
models into production research and
transform data science prototypes
research and Implement appropriate ml
algorithms and tools perform ml tests
and keep updated with the ml trends
the last job role is software engineer
now a software engineer is expected to
write server-side code collaborate with
the design team to gather end users
requirements develop the server-side
platform deploy applications perform
tuning usability Improvement and
automation
moving on to the next topic let's look
at the python developer salary trends
now software Engineers with python
skills are offered better salaries
across the globe the average salary of a
pipeline developer in India is around 7
lakhs 55 000 rupees per annum the
average salary of a python developer in
the US is about 79 000 US dollars per
annum
moving on to our last segment python
developer resume
so let's go ahead and understand what a
python developer resume should portray
just keep a few things in mind when
you're preparing your resume
your resume should be clear updated and
concise
you should prioritize the skills
according to the job role you're
applying for and do not write anything
extra that's a big no the recruiters are
smart enough to know that so do not lie
and do not write extra firstly let's
look at the fresher resuming so if
you're a fresher these are some of the
points that you need to know
first you have the resume header now the
summary is supposed to be clear and
concise just say what exactly you want
and some of your strengths next is the
profile links and your portfolio so you
can mention your LinkedIn profile link
and also your GitHub repository link if
you have next up is the projects now
clearly depict the goal of your project
so just in case you worked on like C5
projects make sure you keep it concise
and crisp next up is your education do
not lie here make sure you give a
relevant education with grades next you
have the certifications if you have any
certifications or achievements go ahead
and write them down next you have the
technical skills now again prioritize
according to the job role and lastly you
have your non-technical skills this
could be your communication analytical
skills problem solving skills Etc moving
on to an experienced developer so again
mention the resume header
then you have the summary again very
crisp and clear go ahead and mention
your portfolios and your links coming to
experience now here you have to clearly
depict your work you'll have to make
sure that you write down all your
responsibilities in that company do not
go overboard and write extra keep it
very concise
again relevant education and your grades
you have technical skills the same goes
for this as well prioritize according to
the job Rule and finally you have your
non-technical skills python has
surpassed French in primary schools this
one certainly seems strange unbelievably
python overtook French in 2015 as the
most widely used Elementary School
language according to Stats 60 percent
of parents would rather want their kids
to Learn Python than French this shows
that a large number of people understood
the value of Python programming
the same stats show that 75 percent of
elementary school students would choose
to learn how to operate a robot over
French are you guys ready to learn the
basics of python today we'll be taking
you through the python Basics full
course this python full course will
cover all the basic level topics of
python by the end of this tutorial you
guys will be able to understand and
deploy basic python projects
let's go through the agenda for this
full course tutorial we'll start this
video with an introduction to python
followed by installing Python and
anaconda in Windows 10. we'll move on
and create our first hello world program
using python
following that we'll cover basic python
topics like variables and expressions
data types in Python and lists and
tuples in Python then we'll move on and
cover conditional statements and Loops
in Python we'll go through the syntax
and usage of all the topics we'll cover
in this video we'll end this video by
going through a mini project in Python
wherein will create certain python
projects with all that we have learned I
hope you guys are ready to learn
something new now we'll start with the
first topic over to our training expert
hello everyone and Welcome to our course
on Python Programming my name is Anish
Karan and I will help you learn the
fundamentals of Python Programming and
what programming in Python really means
and what it is all about I am sure there
are plenty of you over here that are
watching this video that have their own
reasons and multiple reasons to start
learning programming and programming in
Python in particular our goal over the
duration of this course is to ensure
that you are able to Learn Python and
Learn Python Programming to a level in
which you can tackle whatever problems
you have and whatever projects you set
out to do in the future now I'm sure you
must have heard that the some of the
most upcoming fields and some of the
high Prospect domains in in the market
right now such as data science AI
machine learning require Python
Programming and our all in this course
is to get it to a level where you can
start tackling and creating solutions to
whatever problems you may occur whether
it be in your job or in your studies or
anywhere else or any personal projects
that you may take up in the future now
before we actually get started on the
actual Concepts and the fundamentals of
python I want to show you over the next
two or three videos exactly what how
python came to be what was the
philosophy behind creating this language
and uh basically a brief introduction
behind Python and Python Programming so
Python Programming was developed first
by a person a Dutch programmer by the
name of Guido van Rossum and python was
first released by him in the year 1991.
now the design philosophy behind python
was to create a language which was much
easier to read and much easier to
actually code in compared to the or in
contrast to the languages that were
prevalent back in those days such as the
language C now formally python is an
interpreted high level general purpose
programming and what this means is that
python is a it's a language that can be
used for a wide variety of applications
as we will see later uh the high level
part of this definition basically tells
us that python is written in a language
that is very abstract at a much higher
abstract level compared to the
instructions that a computer can
actually read so in layman's term you
can say that python is a very close to
the actual language that we humans use
and that's the way python has been
designed and the difference between a
high level programming language and a
low level programming languages that low
level languages are essentially machine
language instructions that are the
actual instructions that a computer can
actually understand a high level
language like is something that we
humans understand better and we can
write in it better now the term
interpreted over here essentially means
that we don't need to compile our
instructions that we're given python now
as I mentioned earlier that the
computers or any system that involves
Computing needs low level language to be
fed to it so that the computer can
actually understand because computers
cannot understand the way we write our
code and this process of converting from
high level to low level called
compilation and in most languages such
as C there's a special process involved
called compilation which we do after we
create our blocks of code or scripts or
whatever now when we say python is an
interpreted language what this means is
that we can actually work on Python and
see the results right at the get-go we
can skip this step of compilation
because our system that runs python
actually does all of that conversion
from high level to a low level language
as we type our code and this actually
speedens up the process very well for us
and makes programming in Python and
other interpreted languages as well much
much easier for us python is of course
an open source language it's uh the most
bare implementation of python known as C
python is actually even currently being
maintained by a foundation known as the
software python software foundation so
essentially python is being maintained
developed by a group of very talented
developers and it's it's open to pretty
much anyone to work with and to create
libraries for this allows python to be
an amazing language in the in the modern
world because in the modern world we
have different issues and different
problems in different spheres and
domains that we we would need to update
our libraries or update our packages
that we use in our programming language
on a very regular basis and so python
being an open source language allows us
to keep updating and keep up with the
times essentially when it comes to
solving problems now let's go over some
of the features of python and these
features are actually why it's
considered that using python is
advantageous over using other languages
so let's start with some of these points
now as we mentioned python is very uh
it's a very readable program code
readability is very important it's one
of the design philosophies behind this
when it was being developed it's very
easy to learn which is why python is an
entry point for many people that are
just beginning to learn programming and
as I mentioned earlier it's a high level
language in Python we since python is
open source as as I had already
mentioned so it gets it benefits from
all the the benefits you get from any
open source technology now it's also
portable so what this means is that if
we create a code in Python and we create
in a particular system say on Windows we
don't need to make any changes if we
wanted to use the same script or the
same piece of code on some other system
say on a Linux system or a Mac system by
action itself comes with a very large
standard Library this this facilitates
us a lot because we don't need to create
our own libraries or modules or have to
download very specific libraries most of
the problems that we do encounter uh
quite commonly can already be solved by
the standard libraries that have already
been provided by the developers of
python diet right from the beginning now
later on during the course we will
encounter what is the meaning of a data
structure a data structure is
essentially a manipulation of a if of an
object of an object of data and as as
you will see later python has one of the
most user-friendly data structures that
can be found in any language especially
compared to some of its contemporaries
now python is a dynamically programmed
language and this is very important and
what this means is that in most
compiler-based languages we there are
certain processes that can only happen
during the compilation stage so what a
dynamic programming language does is it
takes all those compilation specific
tasks and processes and it does it for
us as we actually type the code so we
don't need to waste time or spend extra
time to do something that would
otherwise be needed to be only done in
compilation we would have to set out
specific uh run time just for that so
this allows us to create our programs
and solutions much faster and allows us
to debug much easier and yeah so it's a
it's a very important feature about
python Now quickly I will just go over
some of the areas of python where like
areas of or different domains where
python is very heavily implemented and
the first one the first few ones that
come to mind are like web development
and Ai and machine learning so you have
Technologies like Django and Flash that
are built on top of python that uh I use
extensively for web development when it
comes to something like artificial
intelligence or machine learning you
have distributions such as Anaconda you
have pandas and many other libraries
like scipy and numpy that are used
extensively too so tackle problems in
this domain and similarly python finds
used in most of the scientific work that
goes on nowadays because of again some
of the libraries that I have already
mentioned such as sci-fi interestingly
if you are into game development or
gaming in general you would see that
python actually has certain libraries
and certain technologies that facilitate
game development very very well one very
popular game in fifth in case you are
into gaming is a world of tanks that is
built on python some of the other
applications are of course desktop
recruiting desktop guis image processing
graphic design applications and
something that is very relevant to me
and of course you as well is is a
creation of education programs and
training courses there are many
Technologies in the environment of
python that were almost designed for the
specific purpose of being able to
present certain Concepts or to be able
to teach certain classes and I can't
think of too many programs or too many
environments outside of python that are
better to solve these Education and
Training course related problems and
situations all right so now that we have
I have covered some of the brief brief
introductory topics around python let's
talk about what we're going to see in
the next video uh we're gonna actually
I'm going to show you how you can
install some of these implementations
and distributions I'm going to speak
about them I'm going to speak out the
certain libraries and modules that they
come with to install python on your
Windows computer it's as simple as going
to the website python.org and selecting
the download section when you reduce
click on download you get redirected to
this website that this webpage that I'm
on out here it by default it will ask
you if you want to download python 3.9
which is the latest version but of
course if you for whatever reason if you
needed a particular version of python
you can download that as well by just
scrolling down and choosing the option
that you want now it's important to note
that whatever option you choose of
course I would recommend the latest one
but no matter what option you choose I
would recommend you choose a version of
python three point something because
previous versions of python namely
Python 2.7 and and basically every
version of python two point something
has it will not receive any more
maintenance and updates because the
developers have decided that python will
they are trying to shift towards the
maintaining and updating python three
point whatever completely right now so
yeah let's not delay this uh any further
and let's download
and 3.9 so once you select the option
out here you'll be you'll get an
installer all you have to do is click on
that and it'll give you two options to
customize installation or install now I
would of course recommend this blue
install now since you're a beginner do
not worry about what a custom
installation is if you have multiple
drives in your system by default the
python will be downloaded into the drive
where your windows is actually installed
your your main drive so as you can see
now that once my setup is done it should
give me a pop-up soon so my setup is
done for Python and this is essentially
how you would download python on your
Windows system but what if you had Mac
OS or if you were using Linux well for
Mac it's a it's actually almost as
simple you just go if you see out here
below this download button python option
you get the website asking you are you
looking for python on a different OS and
it gives you the options of Linux Mac
and even other Oasis but for Mac if you
wanted you would just open this tab and
just like the windows option you would
choose a version and you would choose an
installer for that version so if I
wanted to say python the latest one I
would just download this installer and I
would install in my Mac system now when
it comes to Linux I cannot show you
exactly how you would install it there
are certain commands that you have to
execute but essentially again if you
just choose the Linux option out here it
will take you to a page with a different
installers and essentially packages for
Linux systems in specific what I would
recommend to you if you are a Linux user
and you need python is to go over to the
realpython.com website and they have a
very good essentially instructions on
how to install Python and since I don't
have a Linux system I cannot directly
show you how to install python on Linux
so yeah if you do have Linux please head
over to this website and this should be
of a lot of help to you now as I had
mentioned you can actually really
install python on your mobile devices as
well so if you were say an iOS user you
would go to the iOS App Store and
download an app called the python is the
app for iOS it essentially is like a
full-fledged python environment where
you can develop in Python on your iPhone
or even iPad and if you're an Android
User you could you would go and download
an app called the pi Droid 3. there's a
free version and a paid version for this
app and of course the difference between
the free and pages that the paid
supports code analysis and code
prediction these are certain details you
don't have to worry about right now and
honestly if I wouldn't worry too much
about installing python on your mobile
devices currently since I'm assuming
most people would be learning
programming and programming in Python on
their PCS or laptops it's as simple as
it's actually as simple as downloading
just this thing so if I did a quick
quick Google Anaconda
so the website that I'm looking for is
anaconda.com and I'm looking at products
and I'm looking at individual Edition
there are other editions as well like
commercial Team edition these are for
companies usually or uh for more
professional sort of projects so of
course we are looking at the individual
Edition and if you selected this page
you would be taken to this particular
web page where it will ask you if you
want to download and again there are
options depending on which machine
you're using if you're using a Linux you
would choose one of these two if you are
using Mac OS you would use one of these
two and since I am a Windows user and I
have a 64-bit system this is the option
I would use so again it will it will
first download and install it for you
and as you can see my installer has been
downloaded so upon opening it it will
open up this installation thing you can
just click next on most of these again
if you want to specify your destination
folder you can change it here mine will
be with a default folder in the C drive
and you can leave this unticked you can
you can change these options much later
so this is how you install Anaconda
windows and it's pretty much the same on
other systems as well now once it's done
I will show you what exactly what are
some of the things that Anaconda
contains that are not there if you
installed python like the way I had
shown you earlier just the bare bones
python implementation so as you can see
here my installation is actually
complete and now I will open anaconda
and I'll show you what how you can
actually use this Anaconda so if I
search final count on my system I would
look for something called Anaconda
navigator to actually get started with
this and when I open that it should open
something like this so this is what
opens when you click on the Anaconda
Navigator and as you can see there are a
bunch of applications you don't need to
worry about what these mean right now uh
just understand that this this is
essentially a bundle of different
applications and technologies that come
along with just the normal installation
of python that you get when you install
Anaconda Navigator now now that we have
actually tackled where we've seen how to
install and I'm hoping and I would
recommend definitely that everyone is
watching this video installs anaconda
and not just the normal python
installation or implementation statement
saying hello world so enter in Python
this is how you would go about or this
is the syntax you would use to create
the statement
all right now weight is very important
when you are saving your Python program
that you use the dot py prefix so so if
I were to save this I can choose
whatever folder I am going to choose
yeah this folder seems fine so now I
give the file name over here as say I
want to keep it as test I need to prefix
this Dot py and this uh tells any uh
sort of interpreter or anytime we need
to read the script to know that it's a
python script we need to add a DOT py
otherwise it will not be treated as a
python script it will be treated as some
normal document sort of a thing so now
that I have stored it as dot py I have
created my first python script now
obviously the next question is I need to
see what happens when I execute this
line when I run this script essentially
so to see that there are multiple ways
the first way that I will show you is a
command line method which is obviously
again before we get into it it's not
something that I will be using to teach
you it's not something I would recommend
you to immediately start using
um but for the sake of showing I will
show you how to execute a script in
command line well to do this you go
since I have installed anaconda in my
system and I will be using Anaconda to
work in Python what I will look for is
something called the Anaconda prompt as
you can see this is the option that I
get Anaconda prompt this will
essentially open you a command line
under the environment of anaconda or
python so in this now I am already in
the folder I believe that had my script
so how do I call this script or how do I
run this script well the command is
python space the name of my file which
was test of course the prefix is very
important so I enter test.py if you if
this was in a different folder you would
have to change your folders in command
line which is again something that I may
show you later but since my file is
already in the folder that I am in in my
command line I would just have to enter
this Command right now so if I execute
this as you can see it's given me an
output of hello world which is which is
what I wanted I wanted it to print this
uh these two words and of course the
command line is now waiting for the next
command for me so this is uh one of the
most simple ways of or the most
rudimentary ways of executing a python
script now another question would be
well this isn't the most visually
appealing or not the easy to read or
easy to use way of executing scripts and
I would agree and that's why I'm going
to introduce a another technology or a
software called the IDE so the IDE in
python or in any programming language
stands for integrated development
environment it's essentially a software
that not only allows us to run scripts
but it allows us to create the scripts
it allows us to debug it allows us to
see outputs it allows us to see in
intermediary outputs it allows us to do
a wide variety of tools and tasks and it
comes with a bunch of robust features to
enhance our Python programming
experience so let's let's see so I will
show you a an IDE called spider which
comes bundled along with the Anaconda
distribution that I had mentioned
earlier so if I open the Anaconda
Navigator as you can see the Anaconda
Navigator shows me a bunch of
Technologies and options and I'm looking
for something called the spider IDE
which is over here as you see here it's
a Scientific Python development
environment this is exactly what I'm
looking for so I am looking to launch
this so now that I've launched it you
can see out here this is what an IDE
looks like now this looks very
sophisticated and it's a it's a one and
any almost any IDE is a wonderful
software that where you can create your
code you can debug your code you can
check the results you can make
adjustments changes and you can do a
wide variety of tasks and functions with
relation to your programming so this is
the spider ID in particular and this is
how it looks don't worry about the exact
details just know that on this left hand
pane is our current script that is open
out here and out here we will get the
results in this this is what we call a
console console essentially
so now that we have we have already
created our script in notepad plus plus
and I want to open that script and I
want to see uh how an i how it would the
result of that script would look in an
IDE so let's just open it so we can
browse for our file and as I had named
it test this is the file over here I
open this and as you can see out here in
the left hand pane my script has opened
and the commander had given or had
written is out over here now if I want
to run this application I press this
green button and as you can see the
result of my my execution essentially is
over here it's in slightly small font
but as you can see over here it says
hello world and its way and the next
line is essentially it's it's waiting
for me to do another execution of the
script and then it will give me new
results so let's actually give the
system new results so now that I have
printed something called hello world
let's let's change what's written over
here let's say I will perform
basic maths all right and let's actually
perform the basic maths again don't
worry about the details the syntax uh
what I'm exactly doing these things that
we will actually cover in the in
upcoming videos and modules so let's
create a variable called a let's store a
number three let's create a variable B
Story number five all right let's create
another variable C uh which will store
the result of what's in a and b in the
addition of A and B all right and let's
print the result or print what's in uh
this variable C or what's the result of
a plus b I will print a statement saying
the result of the addition of three and
five is all right and I will put my
result over here as you can see I should
get the result in this pane so let's
execute this and you can see uh my first
line is executed saying I will perform
basic maths and the next line says the
result of the addition of three and five
is eight so this in this script what
I've done is I have performed uh two
print statements and I performed a basic
expression some variable assignments all
of these things we will be doing later
this is what I what I'm essentially
trying to show you is that Ides are a
very convenient way of not only creating
the scripts but actually seeing the
results and then making adjustments as
well we can come we can create a
completely new script we don't need to
create a script from some special file
or text editor I can just create a new
file here and this is my new script
essentially so I can start working on
with this new script right over here
from the get go so Ides are very
powerful spider IDE comes bundled with
Anaconda there are other ideas such as
the I idle IDE stands for
indicated development and learning
environment so the idle IDE comes as
part of the basic python implementation
that I had shown you in the previous
video where you if you just installed a
basic uh python implementation it would
come along with a basic IDE known as
idli or integrated development and
learning environment but of course since
we are using Python and this is what I
would recommend it comes with a more
robust IDE called spider which is
actually very very helpful for
scientific and numeric applications and
was designed specifically with that in
mind now this is not the only way we can
actually work with python there's
another very interesting and a very
educative method of in Python let's say
python programs and it's something that
I will be using extensively throughout
this course to explain different
concepts so this technology is called or
the software is called uh notebooks now
before I get into the details I will
state I will just open node a basic
notebook so the notebook that comes as
part of anaconda is called the Jupiter
notebook and when I open when I launch
the Jupiter notebook this is what I get
now a very important feature or a a
feature of notebooks is that notebooks
are a web browser or a web-based
application so you it's not something
that you can use if you are offline or
disconnected basically if you're
disconnected from the internet it is
something where which for which you
would need an active internet connection
however it is way more robust and it has
very very good properties that allow it
to be used in education or for
presentation and such so as you can see
this is my Jupiter notebook these are a
bunch of folders don't need to worry
about what these are right now I will
show you how to create a fresh notebook
so if you go here and you go to new and
you select under notebook the Python 3
option it will open you your first
notebook as you can see this line is
essentially waiting for me to enter some
sort of a command or a statement that I
would give in a normal python thing now
if you would have noticed the diff in uh
until now everything that we were doing
involved us creating a script which was
the whole series of commands and
functions so if I go back to my spider
IDE as you can see like this is a whole
script and this script contains multiple
different tasks and functions that are
individually being performed so this is
a separate print function this is a
separate Edition another separated print
function and for longer programs or
larger program terms you like you'll
have multiple different tasks being done
and if you were using a script you can
only see the result of something like
this by executing the whole thing at
once you cannot see exactly like what is
the result of just this print statement
or just this uh it's not typically what
an IDE is used for and this is where
notebooks come in super handy if I had
to break down my previous script
essentially where I first did a print
statement where I said some random thing
say hello
yeah so if I execute this particular
line you can see it gives me the result
now I want to do what is 5 plus 3 it
should give me the result over here
eight now in the next another part of
your program might be storing five and
three into variables so I can do this
and I can do this so now this line will
store the variables now I want to do the
addition of what is five plus three but
I want to use the variables and I want
to see what's the result as you can see
a plus b means 5 plus 3 which is 8 and
I've essentially broken down various
different parts of my previous script
into into its individual tasks and I'm
able to see what each part of that
script does and this is very good when
it comes to making presentations or
trying to teach a class so I will
personally be using notebooks a lot to
explain different different concepts of
um different concepts when it comes to
Python and I would recommend that you
get used to notebooks in general because
it's an amazing way to Learn Python
Programming or programming in general in
fact and again as I had mentioned
earlier notebooks are something that
it's an online application it's a
web-based application so I will have to
need a active internet connection to be
able to work on a notebook which could
be a disadvantage if you do not have a
consistent internet connection and in
that case you would probably use your
Ides or text editor which you can be
used offline as well well an expression
in Python is anything that results in a
value its difference although the
difference between an expression and a
standard statement in Python is that a
statement in Python is something that
results in an action or an execution of
a command there is no calculation per se
or any sort of manipulation or as I said
earlier calculation resulting in between
two different same numbers or other
objects that results in a value and this
happens in the case of an expression so
for example if I were to add two numbers
say 5 plus 10 this is an expression
which should where two objects 5 and 10
are being added and a result has been
given to me which is 15. now let's see
an example of a statement well a
statement could be something like a
print statement so when I ask python to
print something for me it's not
calculating anything it's not evaluating
anything it's simply performing an
action that I have or a command that I
have given the system which is to print
whatever I have entered over here as you
can see so this is a statement similarly
there are another type of statement
known as assignment statements which we
will learn actually right in the next
section well let's move on to variables
right now now earlier you might have
learned about objects in Python so
objects are essentially data that we can
work with a manipulate in Python now
variables are a place to store these
different objects usually it's much
easier to store objects in Python
instead of using the objects explicitly
themselves because objects may be very
complicated whereas variables are very
simple to use and very simply very are
named in a very simple manner so that we
can use them quite often in our programs
now it's important to note that in
Python we do not have to explicitly
declare or Define a variable to create
them in fact variables are created in
the same statement where we assign some
object to the variable in Python the
assignment of variables happens using
the assignment operator which is the
equals design so if I were to if I
wanted to assign a number say 100 to a
variable say B well it would be as
simple as doing this now anytime I want
to know what is stored in B I just have
to enter B and I will get the value that
I stored in it and we can store
different types of objects inside a any
variable let's say I store I want to
store this particular word in the form
of a string now this is stored in X and
if I want to know what is an X I can
just see what is here and it's a string
hello which I have stored earlier now
it's very important that we follow
certain naming rules when it comes to
naming our variables in python or else
we may be thrown errors or we might get
some problems in our program so the
first rule is that you cannot start your
variable name with a number so if I were
to give a variable name like 4 num is
equal to something say the same string
hello this would be an illegal variable
name and I would get an error when I try
this so if I were to choose in Num 4 is
equal to hello this would be perfectly
fine I won't get an error the second
rule is we are not allowed to use any
non-alphanumeric characters except the
underscore character while naming our
variable so for example if I were to
name my variable num underscore 4 and I
stay I said random some random strain
this is perfectly fine however if I
change num underscore 4 to num hyphen 4
this will throw me an error as you can
see over here next the third rule is
that variable names are case sensitive
so if if I have a variable called num or
say n-u-m if this was one of my
variables and I stored say the value 50.
this is not the same as me writing num
all in capitals and say storing some
other value 60 these are two different
variables so it's very important that
when you name your variables you are
aware of what case you are writing them
in because python variables are case
sensitive now the final and probably one
of the most important rules in Python is
that you're not allowed to use what we
call Reserve words in Python now python
has a bunch of reserved words these
words essentially are performed or they
are used to perform certain special
functions and are user identifiers for
certain special functions in Python that
we that have a special purpose like that
particular word has a special purpose
within the Python programming language
and you cannot use them to name our
variables so a list of them as you can
see over here some of them are like
false def if Del Rays and there are like
there are around 33 of them and
sometimes some of these words are taken
out sometimes there are more words added
as python gets updated now let's let's
move on to a concept uh where we try to
really understand what do we mean by
storing data inside a variable now when
I say that we are storing something
inside a variable you get an image or
you get an idea in your head that this
variable is like a container where we
store or we put a particular object
inside it so does this mean that
variables have a place in the memory are
they are also an object that is placed
in the memory where we can put other
objects inside of well I'll show you an
example where this idea is kind of
disproven or where I'll show you that
the idea of variable is kind of
different than what we understand by
storing something inside a variable now
let's say I'm storing the same object I
will take this object as some random
number let's say 100 and I'm going to
store it into two different variables so
I take X is equal to 100 over here and
in the next line I will store 100 in y
as well now if objects were I mean if
variables were objects that we placed in
our system then X and Y should have two
different IDs but let's see what happens
when I check the ID of X and the ID of Y
they should be different in case
variables were their own objects however
as you can see the ID of X and the ID of
Y are exactly the same so well obviously
we know that two different objects in
Python cannot have the same ID so does
this so what does this mean when it
comes to the nature of a variable well
the the fact is that variables are not
actually objects in Python in fact
variables are more like pointers or
references to the actual object so when
I said X is equal to 100 and Y is equal
to 100 what I am actually telling the
system is that there is this variable
name called X that I want to refer or
Point towards the actual object that is
in my memory called 100 and I do the
same thing with another variable y so I
am not exactly creating a different
space in my system for these variables
these variables are more like
placeholders or references that point to
a particular place in the memory where
this object is located and that is what
happens when I do ID of X and ID of 5
it's not giving me the idea of something
called X or the ID of something called Y
is giving me the ID of 100 each time
because 100 is stored in X and Y so as
you can see this is something like a
visual representation of what I'm trying
to say and similarly if if I were to so
in this example on the left as you can
see I've used the value of 50 to explain
my point so as you can see initially X
and Y are pointing towards this value 50
because I have stored 50 and 50 in both
X and Y now what if I changed the object
that is stored in X well that means X is
now pointing towards this new object and
I have stored this new object called
hello the string called hello as you can
see here so now X is pointing to a new
object in this system and it's called
hello and I haven't changed anything
with respect to Y so y will Point
towards the same thing and I can also
make the pointer of Y different or what
I'm trying to say is I can store
something else and Y see I stored this
list in y 50 1600 when I do that now Y
is pointing towards a different object
in Python and X is also pointing towards
something else so what happens to this
object 50 well now that there's no
variable referring to the sound check 50
it becomes what we call an orphaned
object and we can actually see that when
we do the ID of X now let's go back to
my example on the right where I stored X
is equal to 100 so as you can see it
gives me some ID represented by this
number now let's say I stored x i stored
something different say 200 now if I do
the ID of X it should give me a
different ID because as you can see the
values are different and this is because
this object 200 is what is stored in X
so when I do the ID of X I'm actually
getting the ID of this new object now of
200 so as you can see Point as you can
see variables are they should be and
they are treated more like references or
pointers instead of containers for a
particular object so I hope in this
video
um you got a brief introduction into the
concepts of variables and expressions
now what are objects in Python well all
the data that we manipulate or use in
our operations in our code are
represented as objects or relations
between objects so if you want an
example two numbers that you add in your
code well both of them are objects and
they usually numeric type objects
similarly if you want to store someone's
name or an address of your home down in
your code you usually store it in a form
of text and that text is also an object
usually a string similarly you might
want to create a container of different
smaller objects inside them and that big
container is also a type of an object
and one of those containers are called
lists and similarly we have many
different types of objects which we will
be covering during the duration of this
course the following pictorial
representation gives us a broad
classification of different python data
types and objects as we can see there
are five broad classifications numeric
which contains integers complex numbers
and floats we have the dictionary data
type we have the Boolean which
essentially consists of objects that
have only two valid values true or false
then we have sets and we have sequence
data types such as strings lists and
tuples every object in Python has three
important properties that kind of Define
that particular object they are its
identity its type and its value the
identity of an object is it can be
considered as a place in the memory or
its address in the memory where an
object is stored an object's identity
does not change when it once it has been
created so for example if I took an
example of say a string called hello I
can use the ID function which is this is
how you use the ID function to find out
the ID of this object and it should be
the answer should be in the form of a
particular long integer so as you can
see the ID of hello is this integer two
three two six four seven six six two
three zero two four similarly all
objects in Python have an identity we
have another operation with regarding
the identity of an object it's the is
operator and the is operator compares
the identity of two objects so if two
objects have the same identity it should
give the answer true otherwise false now
the next property of objects is the type
type of an object is essentially what
defines what kind of values and
operations that that object can have so
for example in numeric data type in
Python such as an integer would allow us
to do arithmetic operations and
similarly string object type in Python
will allow us to do concatenation
operations much like its identity the
type of an object cannot be changed as
well now let's see what's the type of
that particular object that I had shown
you above as you can see it should be
string Str stands for string similarly
if I did a type for a number say 50 it
should give me int as you can see now
the third property of an object in
Python is its value now the value is the
actual data that is contained in the
object it's the thing that we use that
we display that we can manipulate and
then we can perform operations on so so
for example if I were to talk about this
string this string is hello so the value
of the string is the word or the
sequence of letters that spell out hello
and similarly this particular object is
a numeric object with the value of 50.
let's see in this in this pictorial
representation I have shown you that you
can assume this dodge Blue Area as the
memory of the system within this memory
we have objects created called 50 and
hello and this list containing smaller
objects called cat pen and 40. now what
I'm trying to show you here is each of
these objects have a type an ID and a
value and let's see what they are if I
wanted to see as we had already seen the
type of 50 now let's find the ID of 50
as you can see we get this unique ID for
the object 50 which is obviously not the
same as the ID of the object hello above
and the value of this object is the
value of 56 self so that was a brief
introduction into objects in Python
numeric object types in Python are a
broad classification of objects plenty
of common real life applications that we
associate with numerals such as
arithmetic operations and calculus are
done in Python using numeric object data
types there are three main types of
numerals or numeric data types in Python
they are integers float and complex
integers as the name suggests represent
all integer values in Python these can
be such as 100 minus 3 to 305 and so on
floats are used to represent new rules
that contain decimal points such as
100.3 3.9 4.8 minus 6.8 and so on then
there is the complex object type which
is used to represent complex numbers in
Python and this is an example of a
complex number 3 plus 7j this is a
complex number three plus seven J where
the real component is 3 and the
imaginary component is 7 all complex
numbers have a real and an imaginary
component and this is how we denote them
now it's important to note that this J
is a very common symbol in maths and
Engineering used to denote the imaginary
portion of a complex number and it's the
same in python as well so moving on
let's talk about type conversion in
Python type conversion refers to the
conversion of an object from one data
type to another for example from string
to an integer and there are different
types of conversions and let's go
through some of them first of all let's
consider the conversion of something to
an integer and more specifically let's
consider the example where we convert a
string to an integer so let's consider
my example string to be some something
called 145 and I'm sewing this within a
string for a reason because I want to
convert a string to an integer so as you
can see I have stored this 145 within my
Within a variable X and if I were to
confirm that is actually an integer I
can use the type function and see that
it is actually an integer Str now let's
convert this into an integer using the
int function so how would we use it is
simply passing the end uh Sim by passing
the variable that we want to convert
into the in function and as you can see
this is what I've done over here but
before this I will also store it into
another variable all right now let's see
what's in y well y gives us 1 4 5 but
are we sure that it's an end you can
just check it by using the type function
and as you can see the type gives us the
answer end that means that we've
converted the string to an end
interestingly we can convert something
and also specify what base we have to
treat the number as by default when we
pass something in the in function the
program or python will trade whatever we
have passed within the string as
something in base sub decimal but what
if we were to pass something that is
well not in a decimal we could do it
like this now let's store Y and in y
let's store
let's do this and I will show you what
this means X and I will give a comma and
eight what this tells python is well I
want to convert the string in X into an
integer but I want to treat whatever is
an X as a number of Base 8 so 145 is
actually 145 in the base 8. now when we
see what's in y we get 101 which is
different to 145 because well 1 0 1 is
actually the decimal equivalent of one
four five in the base 8. similarly if we
were to give it in the base 2 we would
just replace 8 with 2 over here now next
let's talk about converting something to
a float now as we know float is just
simply something that has a decimal
point so let's convert an integer into a
float how would we do that simply by
using the float function so if I give
120 and I pass this integer through the
float function I should get 120.0 and
these two are not the same though they
may mean the same things to us but in
for python 120 is an integer and 1.120.0
is a different object which is a float
and this is how we convert something to
a float now what if we wanted to convert
an integer to a string well we can use
the Str function we can also use the hex
and the oct function if we want to
convert a particular number to a
hexadecimal or an octal string
respectively let's look at all three
examples say I have a number 688 and I
want to convert this into a string I
just use the Str function around this so
as we know just to confirm let's see
what the type of 688 is this is this
should be an end as we can see but when
we pass when we let's say we convert it
into a string 688 and let's store it
into some variable let's call it a all
right now let's see what's in a it gives
us 688 in the form of a string but we
can confirm by checking the type of a it
is an Str so it is a string similarly we
can use hex if we wanted to convert an
integer into its hexadecimal equivalent
in the in in as an output of a string as
you can see this complex is sort of
complicated thing is actually telling us
that we have converted 688 in terms of
hexadecimals now how do we read this
output this zero should not be treated
as anything it's more like a an
identifier which says that the letter
after this first 0 is the base of this
whole number so it's saying that x x
stands for hexadecimal so it's saying
that 2 B 0 is to be treated as a
hexadecimal number and if you did basic
maths you would find that the decimal
equivalent of 2b0 is 688 similarly if I
did opt if I use the oct function for
688 it will give me the result something
like this so again how to read this the
first 0 is to be treated as an
identifier and not part of the number
what it's saying is the letter after the
first or after this 0 is the base of the
number following these two following
these two characters so as you can see
as you can see what's this saying is
that this whole number is an OCT
represented by this letter O and the
number itself that we are dealing with
is one two six zero and one two six zero
in octal system is the equivalent of 688
in the decimal system so this is how
we've converted a an integer in an
integer into a hexadecimal or a an octal
string now what if we wanted to convert
two numeric objects into a complex data
object well for that we can use the
complex function as you can see here
if I passed complex 5 and say say
something like 3.1 let's see what this
gives us as you can see it gives us an a
complex object where our real part is 5
and our imaginary part is 3.1 so what
this does is essentially you pass two
numbers the first one is the real
component and the second is the
imaginary component it combines to give
you a complex number as you can see here
now let's look at some other type
conversions the next type we will be
talking about is converting something to
a tuple or a set or a list so what if I
wanted to convert a string into a tuple
I will use the Tuple function and as you
can see over here so let's say I have a
string called random let's call it
random all right now if I want to
convert this to a tuple I will use the
Tuple function as you can see over here
the output will give me tuples where
each individual component end of this
Tuple are the individual components or
the individual characters of my string
random similarly if I wanted to convert
the string to a list I would use the
list function and this will give me a
list of the individual characters of the
word or the the string random and I
could do the same thing with the set
function to create a set of individual
characters of the string random as you
can see here so yeah these were some of
the basic python type conversions that I
have shown you as we learn about more
complex data types and different object
types in Python we will learn different
type conversions and functions
associated with them strings are an
object type in Python used to store
textual data this textual data could be
something like for example someone's
name it could be an address of a place
or it could be something like a word or
a sentence now strings in Python are an
object type that is actually a subtype
of a broader classification of objects
called sequences sequences are objects
in Python which contain components
placed one of the other where each
component is given what we call an index
a numeric Index this numeric index
identifies the component in the sequence
and disposition within the sequence now
since python is a zero index based
language the first object of any
sequence is always index 0. the second
is index 1 the third is index 2 and so
on now let's move on to defining strings
how do we Define them well strings are
defined using what we call delimiters
and delimiters occur in pairs in opening
and a closing delimiter in Python these
derivators are pairs of single or double
quotes so for example if I were to use
single quotes to define a string I could
I would do it like this this is a string
as you can see this is a string is
printed over here this is delimited
using single quotes similarly if I were
to define a string using double quotes
it's as simple as doing this this is
also a as you can see now a valid
question arises what if I wanted to
include a single code within my string
well if I try to let's see what happens
if I try to print a statement with a
single quote naturally inside it so say
I'm saying it's my birthday all right
let's see what happens if I try to print
this statement it says invalid syntax
and this is because as I had mentioned
in Python single quotes and double
quotes are delimiters so they have a
special function in Python and we cannot
simply just use them within a string
because python will treat them specially
for a special purpose so what python
will do is it will pair this and this
delimiter so single quotes and say okay
this looks like a string to me and it's
not going to understand the rest of this
and then it will find a random single
quote and it won't find its pair and it
will basically throw us an error because
of this so one way or one word around to
introduce single quotes into a string is
simply to delimit our string itself
using the other type of delimiter or
double quotes So if I want to include a
single code I will close my string using
double quotes So if I did this instead
of what I had done earlier
this is a perfectly valid and legal way
of defining my string and I could I
would do the opposite if I had to
introduce a double quotes within my
string I would use single quotes to
close it so if I were to write a speech
statement she said
I am
hungry all right I have I want these two
double quotes to essentially show that
this is a speech and I'm gonna close the
string using single quotes and this is a
valid way of doing it as you can see my
string has this two double quotes now I
had mentioned that strings are sequences
well let's describe how array sequences
so first of all all sequences in Python
are a
um it's a essentially a sequence of
smaller objects that form the sequence
right so let's try to understand like
how do how are strings to be treated as
sequences some sequences that we will
learn later are like lists or tuples and
in all sequences we can retrieve any
particular object or component in that
sequence using its index and how do we
use indexes in Python well we enclose a
numeric index within square brackets now
let's see what I'm trying to talk about
by this example now say I'm storing a
particular string called say random
within so now my variable name here is
test and I'm storing the string random
within it all right and this is the way
of retrieving a particular uh index from
test I write the variable name and then
next to it I put the square brackets now
I'm supposed to put a numeral within the
square brackets to tell python like what
a particular index I'm looking for so
let's try 0. now as I said python is
zero index based language so the zero
index essentially means the first part
of or the first component of a sequence
so let's see what happens when I ask
python to retrieve the first part of
what is stored in test it gives me the
string R in fact it's just one character
R and it's a string so as you can see it
has given me the first character of the
string random which is R so what this
shows is that this string random is
essentially a collection or a sequence
of one character strings so this is so
Random is essentially a collection of
the string R the string a the string n
and so on together combine to form the
whole string that we call random
similarly if I wanted the character at
the third position of this thing I would
use well since the third position and
since we're working in Python I would
use the index too and it should give me
the letter n as you can see it's giving
me the letter N so this is how we can
show that strings are also sequences in
Python well now let's move on to
um certain string operations and
functions that we can perform well as
you have seen already that we can
retrieve any particular character within
a
um within a string using numeric indexes
well what if we wanted to know what
index is a particular character at then
we can do it like this we use the index
function so let's say my test and I want
to know where where or what position the
character D is in my string random so
this is how I would use the index
function index and within the index say
I'm looking for the character D and now
I it should give me the answer 0 1 2 it
should give me the answer three so if I
execute this it gives me the index 3. so
this is uh the index function that we
could use for our strings now what if we
want to
um say slice a string into a into its uh
into a smaller part you want to slice it
and we want to retrieve only that
particular size well here is an example
say I'm gonna I'm gonna use the same
string called random and it's stored in
test right so let's so one way of so the
way of doing this is like this
now let's see what this let's just see
what this does first as you can see it's
given me a and d and if I went to my
string random A and D is this particular
slice now let's try to understand what I
have done by entering one colon for well
what this has done is it's retrieved a
slice from the first position uh the
first index which is the character a up
until the fourth position which is the
character o but it has not included o so
it's very important when I index like
this every every time I put something to
the right of this colon I am not
including this itself all right so it's
essentially one when I say one colon
four what I'm telling python is give me
the first the second and the third
character but not the fourth one so it's
given me a n and d and it's that's this
is how we do a slicing operation in
Python similarly if I were to say slice
from the first if I wanted only first
and the second character I would do this
is what I would do if I wanted the first
and the second character I would do one
two three so this way it says python
that I want the first I want the second
but not the third off so as you can see
I get a and N now so this is a basic
slicing what if I wanted the portion of
a string from a particular Point all the
way to the right or all the way to the
left well let's consider the example of
where I want the portion of the string
random from the say fourth character
until the left well the way I would do
this is test now since I want it all the
way to the left I don't enter any index
to the left of my colon sign and since I
want everything to the left of the
fourth character I enter 4 here so as
you can see it gives me A R A and D
which is everything from the fourth
character of my string random to the
left similarly if I wanted something to
the right right of it I would just do it
like this I would enter some index here
and I would leave the portion to the
right of the colon blank so this will
give me everything including the third
character since this is how we treat the
indexing in Python everything including
the third character all the way to the
right so this is Dom as you can see now
another perfectly valid um slicing is
say I want to slice or take out
different characters from the string but
I want to skip certain characters like I
want this one then I want to skip one
and I want to take the next one and then
I want to skip one well in that case we
have to introduce a step so one way of
doing this is now how do we read this so
as you can see I've written 0 colon six
colon two so what this is telling python
is I want every character from my string
test starting from the zeroth character
up until the sixth but not including the
sixth after is skipping or taking two at
a time taking two at a time can also be
assumed as skipping one at each step or
skipping one character at each step so
what this will do is it will go to
random it will take the zeroth one it'll
take R and then it will skip the next
one so it will not consider a and then
it will pick n and then it will not
consider D and then it will consider o
up until the sixth character whichever
that whichever that may be and if you
see the output it gives us R and O which
is exactly what we wanted we wanted R we
wanted n we wanted o where we skipped uh
A and D or we skipped the every second
character essentially so this is a way
of slicing strings while also skipping
certain characters or skipping's
characters and steps now python is also
an uh there's another interesting
technique that we can use in Python to
where we can start retrieving characters
from the rightmost side of a sequence or
string we can use negative indexes so if
I were to for example show you let's see
what this what this gives me test what
what is the minus one index it gives me
the character M now remember a string Is
Random so minus 1 gave us the last
character of the string random which was
m so this is a way of using negative
indexes and similarly if I used to test
minus 2 it would give me the second last
character which should be the character
o as you can see here now there are some
other important functions that you may
use in Python for that let's create
another let's create another string
let's call it upper lower all right I'm
sorting it again in the same variable
test let's see what happens when I use
the upper function and what happens when
I use the lower function
now I'm going to use the lower function
for this these two functions will
respectively give out or give us the
result or give us our string in
uppercase and lowercase respectively so
as you can see the upper function
created the first string in full upper
case and the second one created this by
the string in for lower case now another
important and probably one of the most
important methods that we use for
Strings especially when it comes to data
science is the split function so let's
see what I mean by split function let me
create another string let's call it
hello world
all right and I'm going to use a split
function and I'm going to see what
happens when I use this function
essentially so what I'm doing in these
in this these three lines is I'm
creating the string hello world I am
storing it in test and then I am using
the split function on the test and
whatever result I get I'm storing
another variable called sliced and then
I'm just going to show you what is in
sliced as you can see what's happened to
the string hello world is that I have
broken it into its components or its
component words if that makes any sense
into hello and world and I stored both
of these into what we call a list now
you might ask well how does python know
that it has to separate at a blank space
well the split function by default will
break up a string at its blank spaces
but if we want it we could break it up
using or at every comma so for example
if I wrote hello world using comma and
if I put a comma inside over here and
now if I try to execute this
like for example I am going to find I'm
going to look for commas in the string
and I'm gonna try to split it as you can
see there's no splitting happening I
have one list with my original string
itself because it's not found a comma
what if I introduced a comma over here
now let's see what happens as you can
see the splitting has happened it's
found this comma and is caused a split
between hello and World similarly if I
in my string if I put this comma again
and I put something else it should give
me the split over there again so we can
Define our split using some whatever we
put between these Circle brackets after
the split function it's just important
to note that by default if in case we do
not enter anything over here it will use
blank spaces to do the splitting uh
another very important operation and
very common operation in strings is what
we call concatenation so if I have two
strings first and say another string
second and I want to join these together
well the operator I would use to do this
is called the plus symbol this is the
concatenating operator when it comes to
Strings so what is the result of this
let's see let's print this out let's
print this whole thing and let's see
what is the result as you can see what
uh this has done is it has combined the
first string first and the string second
into one string called first second so
this is the concatenate concatenation
operator now finally uh the last Topic
in this lesson is the topic of Escape
sequences now Escape sequences are
special commands that tell python to
either suppress special meaning of some
character or symbol in a string or give
or give the special or give some special
meaning to an otherwise ordinary
character in a string so let's look at
the first example now remember my in my
for earlier in this video where I was I
was telling you like what what is the
way of writing or how do we introduce
single quotes or double quotes into a
string and I had told you the trick if I
want to use a single your coat in my
string I just close it using double
quotes or if I want to use a double
quote I close it using single well
another way of doing this is using what
we call an escape sequence and an escape
sequence in Python is the backslash
character all right so let's see what
happens when I use the backslash
character where I want to introduce my
single code if I use my previous example
where I wanted to introduce a single
quote and say I am going to close it
using single quotes as well so I'm going
to go back to my error example so as to
speak now this would throw me an error
right as you can see it has thrown me an
error so what if I use the escape
sequence that I mentioned the Escape
sequences is backslash character now
this is the point of the string where I
want my my single code so I introduce a
backslash now I have my single quote and
I continue writing the rest of my
statement let's close the string now
will this work as you can see this has
worked so what this has done is this
backslash character has told python do
not trade this special character or the
single quote to not treat it specially
and let it be as a part of the string so
as you can see that's what's happened
here now the next case or the other use
case of Escape sequences is when we want
to give a particular character that is
otherwise just ordinary some special
meaning so let's take the example of the
character T and the character n we use
the character T to introduce tab space
and Views a character in to introduce
what we call line break well let's see
by an example so normally the character
T has no special function so the
character T within a string will just be
outputted as the character T itself
however as you can see here I'm going to
introduce a backslash before this
character t
let's see what it does it introduces
this thing that we called a tab space
which is a larger than normal space
similarly if I were to use the backslash
n combination this would introduce what
we call a line break
and if you were to see the output of
this you can see at the point of the
string where I have this combination of
backslash m a line break has occurred so
there are plenty of other Escape
sequences that you may choose to learn
and uh these are just two of the
probably the most common ones that are
used so yeah this was an introduction
into Strings in Python starting off with
lists lists are a collection of ordered
orbit arbitrary objects that are similar
to what we call an array in other
programming languages but lists are way
more flexible when it comes to python
python lists are a type of sequence and
we might have you might have seen what a
sequence is when we were learning about
strings and much like in sequences or
any other sequence list objects are
assigned a numerical index and whenever
you want to manipulate an object in a
list we use its respective index how do
we Define lists the lists are defined
using square brackets so this is a
simple way or a simple list that I have
just created and assigned to a variable
a let's talk about some of the features
of python lists python lists are ordered
and what this means is that even if two
lists contain the exact same elements if
they if the elements are placed in a
different order the two lists are
actually unique and different and I can
check that over here I have created a
list one two and three and say if I
create another list two and one and
three the same elements were in
different order I will use the is
function to check whether these two
lists are the same and if they are the
same when I use is function it should
give me the value or the answer true and
if they're not the same it should give
me the value false and as you can see I
get the value false because even though
I have two lists with the same elements
they are in different orders and so they
are different and that's what we mean by
lists are ordered the next property for
lists are that they can be manipulated
using their indexes or the elements and
the object inside a list can be
manipulated using the indexes and we
will see that in the section where I
show you list operations the next
property is lists are mutable what this
means is that once we create a list
object we can actually make changes and
modify them without having to create a
new list object the next property is
that lists a dynamic and what this means
is that as we are making or as we are
programming we can actually make changes
to an already created list as we are
programming without having to go through
a compilation stage so if we had to say
increase the or we had to add certain
elements to an already created list that
original list grows in size to
accommodate for these new elements the
next property is that lists can contain
any arbitrary objects so if I created a
list right now where say if I want to
store some numbers
say some floating Point numbers now
and I can put strings as well into my
list all of these are valid uh when it
comes to objects that can be put inside
a list we have no such restrictions so
we can put any arbitrary objects inside
our list the final property that I want
to talk about is that lists are they can
be nested to any arbitrary depth what
this means is that I can put a list
within a list and I can keep nesting it
essentially by putting as many lists I
want within my list and I'm only
essentially restricted by my systems
memory so if I created a list like this
within this say I put any other list and
within this list I put another list I
can keep going on to by keep going on
doing this and I'm only restricted by
the memory of my system that I'm using
so moving on let's move on and talk
about some important list operations
that we will be doing when it comes to
lists so let's create a basic list
called a where I'm storing six numbers
so now say if I want to retrieve a
particular element say if I want to find
out what's on the index 3 this is how I
would do it if I wanted a slice of my
original list and much like strings I do
it the same way so what this does is it
tells python that I want all the
elements of list a from index 1 to index
4 but not including index 4. so it will
give me one two and three index objects
so it should give me 2 3 and 4 in this
case as you can see here two three and
four I can do the same thing by
considering elements say two at a time
if I wanted to consider elements or
consider every second element what I
would do is this syntax I would use this
syntax and when I give this command to
python what it tells what it understands
is I want every element from a from
index 1 to index 4 but not including
index 4 but I am going to consider
considered to every second
element essentially so what it will do
is it will go here and then it will skip
one and then go here and then Skip One
and that's essentially what we uh what
it's essentially what we call
slicing by using strides so I'm taking
strides I'm not considering elements
consecutively but I'm skipping certain
elements in between if I wanted to
consider every third element I would
change this to three and fourth element
I would change this to Fourth all right
so let's see what happens when I take
every second element it should give it
should give me uh it will consider say
from one to index three right so you
should consider essentially this section
but since it's going to skip one it's
going to consider this skip this and
then consider this it should give me two
and four as you can see it has given me
two and four and like in other sequences
we can use negative indexes as well
negative indexing essentially starts
looking from the right hand side of the
list so when I say A minus y one it's
essentially looking at the last element
of the list so it gives me the sixth or
the last element which is the which is
the object six if I did a minus two it
gives me the second last element
similarly another neat trick that we can
use for sequences is the following
syntax double colon and we give a minus
one what this tells the what this tells
the system is I want the list a but with
all the elements reversed as you can see
I get my element uh my list a but the
elements have been reversed right now
let's move on to uh concatenation and
replication where the concatenation much
like in strings is done by using the
plus sign so as we know on either side
of the plus sign should be two similar
objects so if I'm doing a plus something
a being a list on the other side it
should be a list as well so let's add a
list like this now let's see what's in a
as you can see my origin list has a 789
added to it and I can also add things to
the beginning of a list similarly so if
I wanted to add say zero you know at the
beginning for this I just do it like
this
and I get the element 0 added to it it's
very important to note that I I actually
added 0 within a list because if I did 0
like this
it would throw me an error because like
this 0 is just an end object and it's
not a list but when I put the square
brackets I make it a list and then this
concatenation becomes valid because a is
also a list similarly if I did a star 2
this is essentially replication or a
replication function where I'm repeating
the values in a twice if I did a star 3
it's the same function but now I'll have
the elements repeated Thrice as you can
see here let's move on to modifying list
values uh this also shows the mutable
property of lists that I had mentioned
earlier so let's consider this example
so I created a list with elements where
it is the three strings eggs apples and
carrots and I have five int objects one
two three four and five now if I wanted
to change say the first element all I
have to do is take the 0th index and say
if I want to replace eggs with same
mango this is how I would do it now
replace eggs with mango if I check
what's in b you can see the eggs have
been replaced with the element mango
similarly I can use the slice syntax to
replace a particular slice from my list
with a slice essentially so let's look
at this I'm replacing I want to replace
the first three elements I want to
replace mango I want to replace apple
and carrot so what I will do is I will
consider this since this carrot is the
second index so I will consider 0 to 3
because the third is not counted now I'm
going to replace this with three
different
um let's see kiwi
and say sponge now let's check what's in
B you can see my three elements have
been replaced in fact I don't have to
replace like for like if I want to
replace say three elements with only one
or two elements that is also possible so
now if I want to replace the first three
elements give you orange and sponge
with
um just one element this is how I'll do
it let's say
wine now let's check what's here as you
can see three elements have been
replaced with one mine I can double vice
versa as well I can replace smaller
number of elements with a larger number
of elements but here there is a slight
caveat that I want to show you so an
obvious way of doing this would be say
if I wanted to replace the first element
wine with three different elements an
obvious way would be just consider that
elements index and then put whatever
objects you want say I want to add
instead of wine I want to add beer I
want to add ball and say Club yeah well
let's see what happens now if I say B
check what's inside my you can see my
elements have been added but they seem
to have been added as is you know I had
entered a list over here and that whole
list has been replaced uh or this wine
has been replaced by this whole list in
the first position but that's not
exactly what I want wanted I wanted the
elements within this list to be
individually placed into my list and the
way to do that is not this syntax but
actually what I'm going to show you now
if I want to replace one if I want to
replace the index of the object at index
0 I would give this statement a slice
statement where I will give 0 colon 1 so
when I do this and if I
um so let's create my old scenario again
where I had wine and I had one two three
four and five now if I do this B 0 but I
give a slice then this slice is
essentially a single object slice it's
essentially the zeroth index again but
because of this formatting or this this
type of syntax that I'm using what
python will do is now when I say peer
and ball and club now what python will
do is it will not consider this whole
list and add it to in place of uh wine
or whatever I want to replace it will
actually consider the elements inside of
this individually and then replace so if
you see here now if you see my list I
actually have the I've removed wine and
in place of it I've put beer ball in
club but these three are actually
individual objects within my list and
not objects within a list that is then
placed within my original list so this
is an important caveat that you should
take note of so moving on let's talk
about certain methods Associated to
lists let's take a simple list now one
two and three the first operation that I
want to show you or the first method is
the append method so I do a append and
say if I want to append the list by one
object called four
I just do it like this now let's see
what's in a I put so as you can see the
append has put the object 4 into my
original list now say if I wanted to
append three different objects I want to
append five six and seven now let's see
what append function does oh no as you
can see it's done a similar operation to
what we have seen earlier when we gave a
single index or the single element
replacement uh that we saw earlier it
essentially put this whole list into
this particular spot into the list and
this is not what I wanted I wanted five
six and seven to be individually placed
and we do have a way of doing that and
the way to do that is the extend
function that is what I'll show you next
now if I want to extend Say the original
list by three different elements eight
nine ten when I use the extend function
it will not put this whole thing it will
consider each object inside this thing
individually and then add it to a so if
you see my result this is exactly what I
wanted now the next method that I want
to discuss is the remove method so the
remove method is what you how you use it
is within the parenthesis you put the
object that is present in the list that
you want to removed so you don't give an
index over here you give the object
itself so if I want the object eight all
right this number if I want 8 itself
removed what I will do is put the value
8 here and it will remove it from my
list so if I check my list a as you can
see the value 8 has it's gone an X
another similar function to remove is
the pop function now the pop function by
default will remove the rightmost value
from the list but unlike remove the pop
function actually outputs a value and
that value is what we have popped out of
the list so by default it will pop out
the right route right most value of a
list now right most element of a list
and in this case that element is 10 so
it should give me 10 but of course if we
want to pop out any particular object in
this case we will not give that
particular object we give its index so
now say if I want to remove this uh this
list object from my bigger list
um as I can see it's in index 0 1 2 3 4.
it's the fourth index so if I want to
remove the list which is at the fourth
index I give the index value inside the
parenthesis and it pops that out for me
as you can see over here so this was it
for lists let's move on to tuples next
so tuples are another ordered collection
of objects much like lists but they
differ from lists in two Key Properties
first of all the tuples are defined
using parenthesis instead of square
brackets so this is how I would Define a
tuple with elements one two and three
and the next very important property
that is different or that differentiates
tuples from lists is that tuples are
immutable and what this means is that
once we create an object of type Tuple
we cannot make any modifications to it
we would have to only create create a
new object if we wanted something
different and this is obviously a key
difference between a tuple and a list
but apart from this every operation that
we have done on lists are actually
possible to do in the case of tuples as
well so any operation that we did to
lists that did not modify the list or
that does not do any modification we can
actually apply to tuples as well so if I
wanted the first element of this
difficult all I have to do is call it by
the index 0 it should give me the value
1 as you can see if I wanted a slice I
can do that as well it should give me 2
and 3 and if I wanted to reverse my
Tuple well I can use my same neat
technique that I've used for lists and
that I can use for the sequence I mean
strings as well so it gives me my old
Tuple but with the elements reversed so
now the natural question is why do we
use Tuple server lists well one
important difference is that when we can
when we make a program execution where
or where we are manipulating a tuple if
we did the same thing for the exact same
objects in uh that if it were present in
a list it would be much faster in a
tuple essentially program execution is
just faster on tuples when compared to
an identical list so use tuples over
this when we want to be efficient while
we are creating an ordered list of
objects so whenever we create an ordered
list of objects that we don't need to or
we don't want to make any further
modifications to we don't need to create
a list we can create a tuple and another
very important area where we use tuples
over list or why we need a tuple instead
of a list is when we are using
dictionaries dictionaries as we will see
later is a data type in Python that
needs an immutable component while we
are creating the dictionary so if we
want to use uh something that is like a
list but since lists are mutable we can
use a tuple instead and use that when we
are creating our dictionary and we will
see like what what I mean by the
immutable component for a dictionary
when we actually learn about
dictionaries but yeah these are some of
the places where we would use eight
tuples over a list uh a brief section on
Tuple unpacking and packing is what I
would be doing right now and what that
means is that when I create when I give
this sort of a statement
you can assume this to be me packing
this Tuple into a object or a
variability now what's very interesting
is and this is something that's very key
to tuples is that I can unpack a tuple
onto another Tuple so let me show you
what I mean by that so now that I have
packed one two three and four Tuple into
T let's unpack it into another Tuple
let's call this let's uh put these
elements into this Tuple and I put this
into T alright now let's see what I mean
by unpacking something onto something
let's see what's the what what happens
when I put a if I just want to see
what's in a it actually gives me the
value one if I see what's in B it gives
me the value 2 if I see what's in three
invalid 3 and D gives me value four so
essentially if you think of it what I
have done is I have matched this Tuple
then put it into T and then put that
Tuple T into this Tuple a b and c d so
what it's what what has happened
essentially is the element a has been or
a better way to say this would be the
element one has been packed onto or
unpacked onto a two has been unpacked
onto B three has been unpacked onto C 4
has been unpacked onto D to show you
what I've done in a single line is
essentially this this is essentially
what I've done
I have assigned 1 to a 2 to B 3 to C 4
to D I have matched these two tuples
together like this and this is a very
neat feature of tuples the only only
important thing that you have to keep in
mind is the elements of this Tuple and
the elements of this Tuple uh should be
equal so if there are four elements here
there should be four elements here all
right in fact another very important
thing about or a neat feature is that we
don't really need to mention the
parenthesis when we're doing this uh
unpacking or packing so if I did X comma
y comma Z if I did it like this if I put
say 5 and 6 and 7 this is also a valid
way of packing and unpacking so now if I
see what's the value in X it is actually
five if I see what's the value in y it
is six if I see what is the value of x
and z it should give me a tuple
containing five and seven as you can see
over here so this is a neat feature of
tuples called packing and packing so
yeah this is it for lists and tuples and
I hope you understood some of the
concepts around English centiples
dictionaries are another type of
composite data type in Python there are
also a collection of objects much like
tuples and lists and like lists they are
also mutable Dynamic and can be nested
however a key difference and property of
dictionaries is that they are unordered
items and dictionaries are paired using
keys unlike enlists and tuples where the
objects are assigned numerical indexes
to define a dictionary we use curly
braces each key value pair in this
dictionary in a dictionary is separated
using commas and the key and values
themselves in a pair are separated using
a colon let's look at an example this is
a dictionary where I have three key
value pairs as you can see they have
been separated by colons and each repair
themselves are separated by commas and
these are enclosed in curly braces
Define the whole dictionary in this
example these are the keys banana apple
and grape and their respective values
are yellow red and green so this is very
important that in this particular data
type we have what we call a key and that
key is assigned a value and we can have
multiple such pairings and we have three
such pairs in this particular example
another example or the or another type
of way to define a dictionary is using
the dict function this is how we use it
as you can see I have inputted two value
or two object tuples this is a tuple
this is atopal and this is 80 opal and
when I use it in a dict function when I
place it within a list what python will
do is it will consider the first element
of each Tuple as a key and the second
element of each Tuple as its respective
value now if I check what's in D as you
can see the key banana has a value
yellow the key apple has a value red the
key grape has a value green so this is
another way of defining dictionaries an
important note over here is that the the
objects that we use for Keys have to be
of an immutable data type so we cannot
use for example lists as an example of
keys but we can use say integers or
strings for our dictionary Keys also
Keys have to be unique when it comes to
a dictionary you cannot have two
different keys with the or should I say
the same key having two different values
you can have only one key and that one
key will have a unique value assigned to
it duplicate keys are not allowed
however when we speak about values we
have no such restrictions you can have
immutable or an immutable data type as a
value in a dictionary and you can have
duplicates as well so if I created a
dictionary with a key say banana and if
I give if I associate it with it
a value green I cannot create another
key banana and Associate a value yellow
let's see what happens when I actually
do this if you actually see what has
happened here is python has considered
the second case so it's it first looks
at the first pair it goes okay so my
dictionary has a key banana with a value
green but right after it it sees another
key banana with a value yellow so it
overwrites my first key banana with the
second key and it overwrites the first
value green with the second value and we
essentially get one key banana with the
second value yellow so obviously this is
python does this to avoid duplicacies
however if I created a dictionary with a
key banana again if I created I gave it
a value yellow or say green if I created
another
key and if I give this also a value
green this is perfectly fine and this
will not nothing special will happen in
this case because values do not have to
follow such rules let's speak or let's
see certain dictionary operation
operations and functions now so let's uh
bring back our original dictionary which
we had created earlier with the three
pairs all right so what if I wanted to
we can use keys to essentially do these
operations and functions let's see what
happens when we so much like how we use
sequence how we use indexes in example
of sequences we use Keys when it comes
to dictionary so let's see what happens
when we use a key over here so we as we
know banana is a key in this dictionary
let's see what happens when we do where
we give this command it actually gives
the value associated with that key which
is yellow what if we wanted to change a
particular value Associated to a
particular key I would give I would do
this I would give the key and assign it
uh the value that I want to change it
with all right now if I check my
dictionary you can see the key banana no
more has yellow value but the value of
gold what if I wanted to add a new pair
you know a new key with a new value
completely I would do it pretty much the
same same way as I did in the previous
step I would
um essentially write my new key whatever
I wanted say if I wanted a new key
called watermelon I would assign it a
value red and now if I check my
dictionary at the end of the dictionary
you will see that my new key pair key
value pair has been added watermelon red
as you can see over here now what if I
wanted to remove if I wanted to remove a
key value pair from my dictionary I can
use the delete function which is called
by using this the Del function now how
do I do it see if I want to remove the
key value Apple in Red so all I have to
do is do del d and within square
brackets I have to only mention the key
I don't even need to mention the value
just the key so you can probably draw
parallels in how we use indexes when it
comes to lists and tuples and even
strings and how we use Keys when it
comes to dictionaries they are quite
similar so if I did this and if I
um oops I think red is actually not a
key as you can see red is a value my key
is Apple actually it's not red it's
apple as you can see now if I see my
dictionary the key apple and its value
red has been removed so these are some
of the operation that we can do for
dictionaries using keys what if we
wanted to use certain inbuilt functions
that are associated with dictionaries
well some of the examples are as follows
there is a get function when we use a
get function all we have to do is enter
a key inside the parenthesis and it will
get the value associated with that key
so if I gave the key grip let's see what
value is associated with it as you can
see it's green there is also a function
called items that Returns the key and
value pairs in our dictionary as a list
of two object tuples where the first
object is the key and the second object
is the Tuple so let's see what it does
as you can see it gave me a list and in
this list the objects inside the list
are two object pupils where the first
object is always the key and the second
is the value and the same for each of
the tuples so this is what items
function does let's see what the next so
the next function is Keys let's see what
the keys function does as you can see it
returns a list of all the unique Keys
within our list I mean within our
dictionary similarly we can there is a
function for values as well and as you
can see it returns all of the different
values that are present in our
dictionary in the form of a list also
it's important to note that if we have a
particular value that has occurred
multiple times in a dictionary it will
appear as many times it has occurred in
the dictionary or appeared in the
dictionary in our list over here when we
use the value function so if say a
particular value say I had another key
where its value was green again so I
would have the value green appear in
this list once more essentially our next
function is pop item what this does is
much like the pop function in list it
gives us the last entered
um key value pair that is present in our
dictionary so the last centered pair was
watermelon key watermelon with the value
red and that's what has popped out when
we give this function another important
function associated with dictionaries is
the update function and the update
function is a very neat function that is
used to merge two dictionaries together
so say if I had a dictionary let's say
I'm creating a dictionary using the dict
function where I have say some key
called key V so as I had mentioned I
will use two object tuples in this case
and say I give this also a value green
all right and another pair would be same
angle and
let's give it a value yellow
all right so this is another dictionary
that we have created as you can see over
here we have created a dictionary with
the key called key V with value green
and another key mango with a value
yellow and I already have a dictionary D
with these values all right now if I
want to merge these two dictionaries I
can use the update function what I do is
say if I want to merge D with X or x
with d only the ordering will change and
that doesn't really matter when it comes
to dictionaries so if I want to merge D
with X I use D update and then inside it
I put my target dictionary now when I
check what's in D I have the the
dictionary X and its key value pairs uh
merged inside my original Dictionary d
as you can see I have my original ones
here and I have the merged ones over
here so this was the update function so
yeah this was it for dictionaries I hope
you learned some of the important
Concepts surrounding dictionaries so the
first type is the none type it's
accessed through the built-in name none
its truth value is false it's
essentially used to denote
um functions or it's you it's returned
as the value for functions that don't
really return anything so if you have an
expression or a function that returns no
particular value you actually get a data
type called none that is how python
interprets it then there is the ellipses
Ellipsis is something that you might
encounter later it is accessed through
the built-in name ellipses it is used to
indicate the presence of this particular
syntax this particular symbol or
expression or syntax in a slice its
truth value is true again don't worry
too much about ellipses right now next
is numbers and numbers is something that
we are very familiar with we have seen
we work with numbers a lot they are an
immutable type they are created through
numeric literals and they are the
outputs of arithmetic expressions and
built-in arithmetic functions its
subtypes are integers floating Point
numbers and complex numbers within
integers you have plane integers that
represent numbers in the range this
number and this number so this this
number is basically the largest positive
value that you can represent using 32
bit notation in two's complement and
this is the equivalent a for the the
negative the negative side long integers
on the other hand are used to represent
numbers in an unlimited range that is
only subject to the available memory of
your system so these are two types of
integers and as we know floating Point
numbers represent Machine level double
Precision floating Point numbers or
numbers with a decimal point and a
component after that complex numbers are
numbers that contain a floating Point
number that represents a real part and a
floating Point number that represents a
an imaginary part so these are the types
of numbers then we have sequences
sequences are finite ordered sets
indexed uh by natural numbers so each
element in a sequence has an index and
that index is a natural number the
different types of sequences are based
on the mutability whether the objects
can be changed or not is essentially
what we mean by mutability right once we
create an object whether we can modify
it or not and that is how we
differentiate different types of
sequences so they're mutable and there
are immutable types now the different
types of immutable ones are strings we
know what strings are they are sequences
that contain characters Unicode is the
other immutable sequence and then there
are tuples uh tuples are a collection of
arbitrary python objects and unicodes
are sequences that contain Unicode
characters then we have mutable
sequences and uh there is only one
currently there is only one built-in
mutable sequence in Python and that is
list uh lists are also again collection
of arbitrary python objects finally we
have uh well not finally but next we
have mappings and mappings are again
um sets of uh objects but these objects
are now indexed using arbitrary index
sets you know the difference between a
mapping and a sequence you could
consider sequences are ordered but
mappings are not ordered and the index
is given to the objects in sequences are
always numbers they're natural numbers
whereas in mappings they are not natural
number but they are certain arbitrary
objects that we can set for ourselves
again in Python there is only one built
in standard mapping type that is the
dictionary dictionaries are there they
represent finite sets of objects indexed
by nearly arbitrary values the only
condition is that these indexes must be
of an immutable data type so these uh so
what I have mentioned until now are
probably the most common data types that
we encounter or that we have encountered
now so next types are like callable
types such as user defined functions
user defined methods built-in functions
built-in methods classes and class
instances so again callable types as a
whole are referenced using the call
function and this is something that we
will learn when we start learning about
functions when we learn about object
oriented programming and methods and
functions and such the other type are
modules so modules are module objects or
modules essentially are referenced or
called using the import function again
modules can be considered as these large
libraries or larger pieces of code or
applications that we that contain
various different methods and functions
and objects and classes within them
again modules are something that we will
think about a little later files are
data types that are called using the
open function so anytime we and as we
will well during the course of this
tutorial we or during the course of this
this course essentially we will be
working with a lot of files these some
of these files are text files some of
them are comma separated files so all of
these files that we open using uh the
function open or some other certain
specific functions where we create file
objects out of these files these are
what we call file data types finally
there are internal types that are used
by python interpreter again this is
something that does not concern us right
now but just know that The Interpreter
for python uses these data types for its
functioning so this was again this was a
very brief
introduction or explanation into python
type hierarchy and as you can see in
this table there are different types
such as addition subtraction
multiplication so let's go over them one
by one so a simple addition operation
would be like 5 plus 6 giving me the
value of 11 I can do 5 minus 3 that's
subtraction similarly I can do a
multiplication using five say five into
two there's division where I use the
backslash so say I did division of 8
divided by 2. now you might encounter
another type of division which is called
the flow division where we use a double
backslash and what this does is it
returns us the largest whole number that
is lesser than the result of our
division so the division difference
between the float Division and and the
normal fluid and the floor division or
the single and the double backslash is
this say I did 9 divided by 2 using a
single backslash it should give me as
you can see 4.5 right so this is the
actual value now let's see what happens
when I do 9 double backslash 2 it will
give me 4 which is the largest number
lesser than or equal to 4.5 that is also
a whole number so this is what we call
floor division essentially finally we
also have if we want to raise something
to the power or something so if I want
to do fire I say 6 raised to the power 3
because I would use double asterisks and
this is how I would do it it'll give me
216 as you can see uh if I wanted
remainder between the division between
two different numbers I will use the
percentage sign so if I wanted the
remainder of the division between seven
and three this is how I would do it I
get the answer 1 as you can see so next
category of operations are logical
operations the first one is the logical
and operation where we use the operator
end all right so let's see what we mean
by this I am creating so as we know the
and operation Returns the value true if
both the operands are true so let's
actually let's actually do this for an
example let's give this variable the
value true and this the value false so
it should be done like this false so now
think of it like one and zero so a one
and zero is obviously zero right so if I
did A and B I should get the answer
false or zero because I'm doing true and
false so it's like doing one and zero so
if you see this I should get the answer
false if I change this to true as well
now if I do this I will get the answer
true as you can see uh the next logical
operation is the or operation where well
logical or is if either of the operands
are true then we should get the answer
to our or operation as true as well so
in this case obviously if I did or over
here it will naturally give us true if I
change this to false
it should again give us true and it will
only give us faults if both are false as
you can see here now it's false the next
operation is The Logical not uh it's
done by using the not operator so in
this case the value that we get is true
if the operand is false so let's take a
as we know a is false over here so if I
did not a I should get the answer true
but if I change this to true now if I do
not a I should get false as you can see
so this was The Logical operations let's
move on to the next set of operations
that is comparison operations so there
are a bunch of them let's go over them
one by one if I want to check if two
operands are equal so if I did X is say
equal to 2 and now Y is equal to 3. if I
want to check if they are equal I will
use the double equals to sign and if
they are equal I will get the value true
if they aren't either I'll get value
false as you can see since X is 2 and Y
is 3 as you can see X and why are not
the same so there's false they are not
equal if I change this also to 2 now I
will get the answer to another the next
comparison is the not equal to or where
we use the exclamation sign so over here
this is this the result of this is true
if X and Y are not actually it's the
same so I should get false over here as
you can see but if I change this to say
5 now I will get true because X is not
equal to Y in this case the next one is
greater than so if I did X greater than
y as we can see 2 is not greater than 5
I will get false over here similarly
there is a lesser than if I did X less
than y I should get true over here as
you can see well there's also a greater
than or equal to and lesser than or
equal to which simply add the equal to
sign here so let's see now if I say x is
lesser than or equal to 3 I should get
true because X is 2 and if I put 2 here
I should also get true but what if I put
1 here since X is equal to 2 and 2 is
not less than equal to 1 this is a false
statement and I can do the same thing
with like this using the greater than
equal to now it's true because 2 is
actually greater than equal to 1. and so
this was comparison operations the next
set of operations that we can do in
Python are assignment operations we've
already seen a whole bunch we've already
been assigning values to variables we've
been doing assignments throughout
already but let's go over them and see
some of the assignment operations so as
we already know the equal to operation
is assigning everything that is on the
or the value on the right hand side of
the equal to sign to what is on the left
so if I did a is equal to 5 plus 6 it
will assign the value of 5 plus 6 or 11
to a let's check what's in a as you can
see it is 11 there is a plus equal to
sign and what this does is so for
example if I did say a now since a is 11
let's create another variable called B
and call this 5 all right so now if I
did a plus equal to B what this will do
is it will add B to a and then store it
in a so let's see what this does once I
do this now let's check what's in a it
should be 5 plus 11 as you can see 16.
so this a plus this is this plus equal
to sine is essentially the same as doing
a is equal to a plus b it's essentially
the same thing they're both the same uh
there's a similar thing for this the
negative or subtraction as well minus
equal to so now that a is 16 and B is
still 5 of course if I did minus equal
to B now I'm subtracting the value 5
from 16 so I should get a is equal to 11
again as you can see here and this is
the equivalent of doing a minus B A is
equal to a minus B Min as you can see so
uh the next similar like assignment
operation let's create a is equal to say
6 in this case and say B is equal to I
will say A2 right now if I do a star
star equal to B what this does is it
multiplies B to a and then assigns it
back to a so if I see what's in a now it
should be 12 as you can see here
similarly there is similar thing for
subtraction as well so if I did a is
equal to 6 and B is equal to 2 and if I
did a sorry for division so if I did a
division symbol and equal to sine and
then if I give B what it will do is it
will divide a by b or 6 by 2 and it will
assign that back to a so my value in a
should be 3 as you can see here 3.0
obviously this is a single uh single
backslash so this is a float division
the resultant of a single backslash is
always a float I can do the same thing
with a double backslash so let's see if
I did a is equal to 7 now and then B is
equal to 3. now if I did a double
backslash equal to B now it will do the
same division but uh it will do a floor
function so it should give me 2 in this
case if I did the same thing with a
single backslash just to show you the
difference between single backslash and
double backslash division in this case
it will give me
um the value around 2.3 or something a
float basically 2.33 as you can see here
then there is the modulus you can use
the modulus sign as well with this
assignment uh say a is equal to say 5
now B is equal to 2 now if I do a
percentage symbol equal to 2 I mean the
it should give me it will assign the uh
it will take the modulus in both sides
and then assign it to the left hand
upper end now let's see what's in a as
you can see it it did a divided by 2 the
modular symbol is basically the
remainder of the division between two
objects so in this case it will divide a
by B and then give me the remainder and
then put the remainder back in a and as
you can see the remainder of 5 divided
by 2 is 1 and we get that over here
similarly we can also do exponential so
if I have a is equal to say 5 b is equal
to 2 and I want to raise a by if I want
to raise the value of a by the value of
B and then store that back in a this is
how I would do it so it should be 5 to
the power 2 which is 25 as you can see
here so this is assignment operations so
finally we move on to uh two special
sets of operators one is the identity
set identity operators and the other is
the membership operators uh let's look
at the identity operators so when we
talk about identity operators what we
when what we mean is the is and the is
not operator so what the is operator
does is it checks whether two operands
uh have the same location in the memory
essentially this does not mean that it
does not check for whether two objects
have the same value and this is very
important so let's look at this if a is
equal to one thousand and one and B is
equal to 1000 plus one all right if I
did a is equal to 2. this is an equality
check are they the same values true now
if I say a is B let's see what happens
as you can see it's false this is
because this object and this object are
not the same and and this is what the is
Operation does we can confirm this by
checking the ID of a the ID of a gives
us some value like this and the ID of B
gives us as you can see a different
value so the two objects are not located
in the same place in the memory as we
have seen using the ID function and that
is what we check through the is operator
and the is not is essentially just the
opposite of that so so that is the
identity operator now the membership
operator is used for checking whether
something is present in a sequence or
not so let's create a sequence I will
create a list to show in this example my
list is 1 2 and 3. basically simple list
with three integer objects one two and
three I will check whether now say 2 in
a so is 2 in a if it is it will give me
true as you can see is 5 in a it should
give me false because 5 is not in a and
the a naught in operator is just the
opposite of that it checks the other
condition essentially so this is the
membership operators in Python so this
was it for operations in Python so of
course there's confusion when we don't
know which operator has precedence over
the other and in Python there is a
strict precedence that is followed in
such scenarios so this table gives us
the Precedence so as we can see the The
Operators at the top are at the lowest
precedence and as we go down we get
operators with higher precedence over
the ones above them so the low of The
Operators that we have seen the or
operator the and and the not have the
lowest precedence so R and not and then
we have comparisons and identity
operators such as the equal to equal to
sign the the exclamation equal to sign
so these operators come at the next
level then you have addition and
subtraction followed by multiplication
division modulus and floor Division and
finally the highest precedence of all
the operators that we have seen till now
is is the exponentiation or the double
asterisks so let's see a couple of
examples that explain this point a
little more so as we can see in this
line we have 20 plus then there's a 5
and asterisk 3 minus 25 and we want to
know like okay what is the Precedence in
this case so as we know we have the plus
sign we have a minus sign and we have
the asterisk sign so we have addition
subtraction and multiplication so which
one will take precedence over the other
well let's refer to this table as you
can see the addition and subtraction
have lesser precedence over
multiplication so this multiplication
will happen first so we actually do 5
into 3 first we get 15. after that we do
plus and minus so we get 5 into 315 then
we add it or we can subtract over 25
that does not matter so we do 5 into 3
15 and then we do 20 plus 15 which is 35
minus 25 so we should get an answer 10
as you can see we do get the answer 10.
another example would be where we have
this plus symbol we have a double
asterisk talking which shows
exponentiation and a subtraction and a
division so again as we know
exponentiation has the highest
precedence so in this whole operation or
this whole expression we first do the
operation associated with the
exponential so we do 5 to the power 2 or
5 exponent data exponentiated by the
power 2 so we have 5 to the power 2
which is 25 now we look at okay once we
have that we still have a addition and
we still have a subtraction and we still
have a division simple and as we know
division takes precedence over addition
and subtraction over here so once we do
this we finally move on to this step
where we do the division of 6 divided by
2 where we get three so we have 25 from
this 5 to the power 2 which is 25 and we
have 3 over here so now we do 20 plus 25
which is 45 minus 3 which is 42 and as
you can see that is the answer over here
let's look at the precedences when it
comes to certain of the certain um
comparisons or The Logical operations or
the comparison operations so as to speak
so I've created a variable called season
with the string summer I have created
the variable age with the value with the
string 10. so you don't need to put it
in a string so I have the int object 10.
now I have the color a variable called
color with the string pink now I'm going
to see in this line I'm going to do an
if and else statement so if you don't
know what an FNS statement is just
follow along with me so what this does
is if this condition is met I will print
this statement otherwise else I will
print this statement now what is this
first condition it is saying season
equal to equal to Summer whether this
variable is equal to the string value or
as we know about the or operation age is
equal to this and color is equal to
equal to Pink So as we can see in our
comparisons and our logical operations
the Precedence for or and not is or is
the lowest precedence uh and is above
that and the naught is above that in
this we have the or and we have the and
so of course the first check is the and
function so it's going to check whether
this whole condition and this condition
are it's going to come it's going to do
that operation so it's going to do this
and this so is color pink color is
indeed pink okay so this this part is
true now let's see if this part is true
as well now once we're going to check
whether this is true or not what we need
to see see is this condition itself has
an or statement so the first part of it
is saying is season summer season is
indeed summer as you can see here next
part is saying is age greater than zero
but this does not matter since the r
function just needs one of the operands
to be true and in this case this is true
in this case it is also true so this is
this whole statement is true as well so
once we have this statement as true and
then this statement is true we can we
finally move on to we come back to this
and statement and we say since both the
operations or both the operands I'm in
are true the resultant of this and
should also be true and since this is
true this whole condition we actually
move into this section of our ins if
else condition where we say okay we can
uh do this statement this print
statement and we do not have to print
this particular thing so our answer
should be our result should be the
printing of the string this string okay
as you can see the OK string is actually
what is printed over here so this is an
example on operator precedence of course
it's it always helps to you know try to
fiddle around on your own uh create
random Expressions out of like out of
the top of your head and see how exactly
python is uh evaluating that and try to
understand break it break it down on
your own and this is probably the best
practice you can do to understand
operator precedence so starting off what
is this math module well uh the python
map module is an important library or a
feature that is uh designed to deal with
mathematical operations this math module
is part of the basic python installation
so you don't have to install this
separately to use this math module all
you have to do is import this module and
this is how you would do it you just do
import math and this will import your
math module for you to use in your
programming and in this in the course of
this video I will be showing you certain
Concepts surrounding the math module
such as what are the constants that come
with the mass module some of the
arithmetic functions is the
logarithmetic functions power functions
and even trigonometric functions that we
can do using this mathematical and the
function inside the math module so
starting off let's look at some of the
constants that are part of this so as
you can see the standard constants are
available in this module are Pi there is
Tau there is Euler's number Nan which is
a special it's a it's a programming
specific concept and infinity so let's
look at this one by one so starting off
our first constant is pi
um Pi is as you know in maths it's the
ratio of the of a circles circumference
to its diameter and Pi is an irrational
number you know the value of pi is 3.14
something since it's an irrational
number it does not we cannot Define it
in terms of a specific fraction but it
can be approximated to the fraction 22
by 7. so how do we access this by
constant is simple as this once you have
imported maths the maths module all you
have to do is do match dot pi and it
will give you the value as you can see
so as you can see the value returned to
us is a float this is important to note
and the number of number of decimal
digits uh the number of digits after the
decimal point that we can see here are
15 and this is like a by default thing
for python that if you call the pi a
constant it will give you the value of
pi correct up to 15 decimal points so an
example of where we can use this thing
is say we have the radius of a circle 3
it can be an N units three meters or
whatever you want and you want to find
out it's say circumference so as we know
the circumference of a circle is 2 pi r
so if I had to find the circumference of
a circle in my in my code for some
application with the radius 3 or all I
would have to do is use the formula 2 pi
r and uh to call the value 2 pi r
instead of specifically writing 3.14
something I can just use this function
math dot pi over here and then I can
enter the r as you can see it will
return me the radius as you can see so
moving on uh the next constant that we
will talk about is Tau Tau is similar to
Pi in fact tau is the ratio of a circle
circumference to its radius Pi is the
ratio of a circle's circumference to its
diameter and tau is the ratio for
circles circumference to its radius so
important to note this difference so
because of this definition tau is always
two times the value of pi this is by
definition and much like Pi if you call
the Tau constant in you from the math
module it will also return you a float
number and to find that this is the
function that we use this is the syntax
so as you can see this is this is
actually two times the value of pi 6.283
and even this is returned correct up to
15 uh places to the right of the decimal
point and this is by default next
constant is the Euler's number the
Euler's number is a it's one of the most
widespread constants used in the world
of uh in the scientific community in the
mathematical Community
um you will be using the Euler's number
probably a lot as a if if you move into
data science or AI or something like
that so what is the Euler's number it is
uh it is the base of the natural
logarithm if you know what the natural
algorithm is it is used to calculate
rates of growth or rates of Decay and as
with number is a constants like pi and
Tau even the Euler's number is an
irrational number with infinite decimal
places uh the value of the Euler's
number in short it's denoted by the
small letter e so this value of e is our
usually approximated to around 2.718 so
how do we call this uh constant is
simply as math dot e this is how we do
it so we you get this value again this
is also a float and it's correct up to
15 decimal places so the next concept
that we will be talking about is
infinity now Infinity is a it's more of
a mathematical concept and this is very
important to note because Infinity
doesn't is not really a number there is
no number called Infinity it is it is
used to define something that is
infinitely large or infinitely small so
positive Infinity is something that is
higher than any known number to us and
negative Infinity is lower than any
known number to us so this is the
concept of infinity and how do we call
this uh function well so let's see what
happens when we call the math function
math constant Infinity so this is how we
do it and as you can see it will return
us this it might look like a string to
you but this is actually a special type
in Python
um which is not a string this is also a
float it's a type of a float in fact
this Infinity value it's it's a it's
like a special data type it's a special
data type that you can you can consider
as an equivalent to a float but it's not
it's not a typical float that we know
like you know 3.14 or 2.71 the value of
method.inf will give us
um INF and this is this INF is actually
not a string so we can we can confirm
that over here as you can see when I do
a type when I check the type you see
it's actually a float in fact this was
recently added in Python 3.5
um a special type known as math.inf it
returns this INF data type which is
equivalent wave float so this is this is
how we use Infinity if you wanted to get
the value of say minus infinity all you
would have to do is match dot INF with a
minus sign preceding this constant and
you will get minus INF now let's check
if the concepts or the properties of
infinity are maintained you know like
every a positive Infinity is greater
than any number that we know and
negative Infinity it is greater than any
number that we know so let's just
confirm this so I will take method in
and I will do a check is this greater
than say some really large number
something that comes off the top of my
head immediately okay so let's see if
it's if this is true then this is
conceptually correct and as you can see
it is true in fact I can change this
number to anything as large as I want
this will be true because Infinity is
true is larger than any number that we
know and similarly if I did minus math
dot in INF and I checked some very small
number you know a very very small
negative number so just consider some
minus 10 to the power something right
this should also be true uh sorry it
should be in a small descent symbol this
should also be true because I'm checking
minus infinity it's smaller than any
known number it was and it is true as
you can see so it's very uh also if you
did a if you did something like so let's
say if we do let's add something to this
you know it's a number so we should be
able to do arithmetic on this let's
actually see what happens when I add say
10 to positive Infinity it actually
gives us the same value back infinity
because intuitively we know that
infinity plus anything is still going to
be Infinity right and this is exactly
what python does for us even if we add a
number to this the math dot INF or the
infinity constant in Python it will
still give us the same value the same
data type of INF or Infinity similarly
if we subtracted something from the
negative of maths.inf you know say minus
say again let's say minus 100 so if you
subtract something from minus infinity
we're technically still minus infinity
itself so this will again give us my S
and then minus INF as you can see and
this is absolutely what we need and this
is a very very interesting feature in
Python finally the last constant that we
will discuss is the Nan or the not a
number constant so this is not really a
mathematical constant uh there is no
constant in maths called not in number
this is a computer science related
concept that it's used to is used to
denote invalid inputs or in it's used to
indicate a certain places where say a
variable that should have a number
um it's been corrupted for whatever
reason and it it now has a text or a
symbol and our code throws an error then
in these in these cases where python
expects a number from us or from your
code and it does not get it it will
throw you a n a n value and this is
usually used in cases where you have
errors in your code so again just to
check like what this this constant like
how to call it this is how you actually
do it maths.nan and it will give you a
data type called Nan also much like the
infinity constant let's see what's the
type of this
um this constant again might look like a
string to you but of course this is not
a string this is enough a numerical
concept and as you can see it's still a
float so this is like um it's another
special uh data type that was created
for specifically this case where uh it's
some it's the equivalent of a float but
um it's not really the typical float
that we are that we associate with so
this is a constants in the math module
so our next topic will be arithmetic
functions that we can do in the using
the math module so some of the common
arithmetic functions that are available
to us are factorials the ceiling
operation floor operation uh there's
permutations there's combinations you
can find the greatest common divisor or
the gcd and the LCM or the least common
multiple and you can truncate numbers so
let's look at them one by one so
starting off with the factorial
operation the factorial operation is
done using the factorial function as you
can see here actually is defined like
this math dot factorial all right so now
what we pass in between the parenthesis
will be uh what we calculate the
factorial for as you know factorial is
so factorial is always for a positive
integer and the factorial for say a
number 10 would mean 10 times 9 times 8
times 7 so on until the number one
obviously factor is only defined for
positive integers uh it is not defined
for negative values or it's uh and it's
also not defined for decimal values so
let's see let's look at an example so as
we know
um so let's say we pass maths dot
factorial for six and let's see what's
the value so this is exactly what we
expect so we expect the value of 6 times
5 times 4 times 3 times 2 uh that is
actually 720. let's see what happens
when we pass 0 this should give us one
since we know 0 factorial is one now
let's see an error case where we pass a
minus 5 as you can see this will throw
us an error because factors are not
defined for negative numbers now Moving
On Let's uh so the next function I will
talk about is the ceiling function so
the ceiling function is defined using
math dot CL as you see here so again we
pass the number that we want the ceiling
for in between the parenthesis so what
is the Searing function it gives you the
largest uh sorry excuse me it gives you
the smallest number that is uh greater
than or equal to what we pass over here
so for an example if I give you 6.6 and
I asked you okay what is the ceiling
function for 6.6 it should give you 7
because 7 is the largest integer
integral value that is greater than 6.6
or equal to it obviously if you give the
ceiling function for an integer it will
give you the integer itself so let's
look at an example 7.8 so this should
give me the value 8 as you can see here
let's look at another negative number so
minus 12.3 an integer that is greater
than minus 12.3 uh is minus 12 the
smallest integer that is greater than
minus 7.3 and this should give you 12 as
you can minus 12 as you can see here a
similar function is the floor function
which is defined like this again the
floor function what it does it gives you
the greatest number that is smaller than
whatever value we pass between the
parenthesis so if I gave it 2.3 it
should give me the value 2. again if we
pass integers it will just give us the
integer itself again that is to
reiterate this ceiling and flow
functions they give you into integer
values so the floor function will give
you the largest integer that is smaller
than what we pass over here so let's
look at 6.7 so the largest integer that
is smaller than 6.7 is 6 and as you can
see this is our answer over here uh the
next function that we will look at is
the truncate function the transcript
function is defined using this truncate
is very similar to what we have seen
this is how we Define the rocket
function uh it is very similar to the
ceiling and floor in the truncate
function what we do is
um we pass a decimal value a float
number to the between between the
parenthesis and what we get back is the
number without the decimal component so
only the integral component so if I gave
it 7.8 for example it will give me only
the seven part it will return me only
the seven part and I will chop away the
point eight part if I gave it minus 12.3
uh it will chop away the 0.3 part and
give me only minus 12 back so let's look
at an example 8.9 it should give me only
eight as you can see here see I did
minus 8 or minus
6.9 this will give me -6 so you can
think of truncate function as it does
the floor function for positive values
and it does the ceiling function for
negative values because it rounds down
and rounds up respectively for positive
and negative values so now let's look at
the next set of arithmetic functions
let's move on to permutations
permutations are defined using this as
you know so in between the parenthesis I
have to pass two values n and K okay so
I have to pass n n and a k the K has to
be less than or equal to n because the
permutation as you know is uh the number
of ways in which we can permute from n
objects K Tire K different objects uh so
what this mathematically what this is is
um permutation of N and K is n factorial
divided by n minus K factorial so if I
pass say 10 and 6 it will give me the
permutation of 10 and 6. so let's look
at what's the value as you can see it's
a very large value 15 151 200. similarly
there is a combination function and this
is a combinations of permutations are
used a lot in probability so if you're
going to move into that sphere which you
will encounter a lot in machine learning
AI you will be using these functions
quite a bit
um so the combination function again you
pass an n and a k again the N should be
greater than or equal to this K what
this evaluates is n factorial divided by
n minus K factorial times K factorial so
again this is a mathematical concept so
let's look at the permutation sorry the
combination of 10 and 6. so as you can
see it gives me 210 which is the
combination of 10 seconds in the
arithmetic function section
um our gcd and LCM as we know gcd is the
greatest common divisor LCM is least
common multiple so as of the newest
version of python in three point python
3.9 the math module gets these two new
functions that were very lately added
actually
um since uh I cannot show you that
because I don't have the absolute latest
version of python on my system but using
the
math.gcd function this is the function
and in between this we would what we
would do if we had the latest version is
we would pass two numbers or as many
numbers in fact and what this function
will do is find the common divisor
amongst them so if I give these say for
example if I gave these numbers it would
give me the value 10. similarly the LCM
function again added in the python 3.9
finds the common multiple amongst or
whatever we pass over here so if I
passed say 20 and 30 this will give me
uh the value of 60 which is the LCM of
20 and 30. so again these are it's
something neat that if you say you have
python 3.9 or uh if you have python 3.9
or after that uh you will have access to
these functions as well if you when you
import the math module so that was for
the arithmetic uh functions let's move
on to the next section which are power
and logarithmetic logarithmic functions
so let's start off with the power
function
um there are two there are uh multiple
ways you can actually do a power
function in math in Python so you can do
something like this which is the
equivalent of 2 to the power 3 or you
can use the inbuilt uh module math and
you can use the pow or the power
function which is this is how you do it
and if I had to do same 2 to the power 3
I would just pass 2 and 3 has arguments
like this and it should give me the
value as you can see 8 over here what if
so there's actually one more function
which is simply the pow function and
this is uh not part of the math module
it's a function not part of the math
module but it's still part of the base
python use this as well and you can do
the same thing pow 2 and 3 it should
give you the value 8 again the you know
you might ask what's the difference
between these two functions well it's
not much for at least in a beginner
standpoint it's not that much just note
that the maths dot power function is
slightly computationally faster than the
simple power function so yeah moving on
their next topic would be the next
function that we'll discuss is the
exponential function which is defined
like this again exponential function is
again e to the power something so if I
did exponential of 3 this would give me
e to the power 3. so as you can see oh
of course I did not Define the module
beforehand so math.exp now when I do
this it should it will give me some
value which is basically Euler's number
or e to the power 3. so this was the
exponential function and let's look at
an example so we will look at the
example of rate of d k and we will use
the uh this function in that example so
the exponential rate of Decay
um uh for uh is used to calculate the
amount of radioactive elements that is
present in a substance after a certain
amount of time so the the the the the
expression is uh something like the
initial amount of radioactive elements
that were present uh right at the
beginning times the exponent of minus
693 times t t for time divided by the
time period the half-life time uh so
let's just write it down to make it
simple so again as you can see the uh so
this will give me the remaining amount
of radioactive elements right so let's
uh slide down remaining let's assign
this to a variable remaining so the
initial again
um initial is the initial amount of
radioactive elements so let's give it
some value say 100
um the time let's assume it's 10 years
and let's say the half-life
um Half-Life is around I don't know
let's give some value say three or
something again this is uh the details
are not important so this will I'm using
the math dot exponential function over
here as you can see and for these values
uh now when I check what's the value of
remaining after I calculated it it's
something uh so this is it's basically
what this tells me is that I started off
with 100 units of some radioactive
element
um and in 10 years this is what is left
so yeah so this is how we would use say
the X exponential functions in a
particular example of ours so next the
next type of again functions are
logarithmic functions so let's look at
some of these algorithmic functions that
are part of the math module so basic log
function would be written like this math
DOT log in in between this I would pass
the number that I want the log for by
default if I just pass one number it
will it will calculate the log of 8 to
the base of e as we know e is the
Euler's number so let's see what it does
in this case it gives me some value what
if I wanted to specify a particular base
well I would pass a second argument in
this case I want to find the log of a to
the base 2 this should be the value 3 as
you can see over here uh there are two
specific functions that are also
provided in this math module that is log
2 uh what this will do is again it will
again I have to just pass one argument
and this will automatically find the
value of the log of 8 to the base 2. as
you can see here similarly there is a
math DOT log 10 function if I give if I
did this I will find the value of
something here to the base 10 as you can
see so this was a logarithmic functions
then you have the finally you have the
square root function so how would we use
the math the square root function is Max
dot sqrt again we pass the what we want
over here if we want the square root of
say 49 this should give me the value 7
as you can see finally maybe move on to
the final set of functions that we can
do using this math module uh they are
trigonometric functions and they are
hyperbolic functions so let's start off
with some of the trigonometric functions
as we know
um we can do sine we can do cosine and
tan uh some of the basic functions the
way we would do it is math DOT sign in
between this what we this is to
calculate the sign of a particular angle
and this angle must be passed in radians
and this is very important to note we do
not pass it in degrees but in radians so
if I say past sine of 3.14 as we know
3.14 is an approximation of the value by
sine Pi is supposed to be in fact it's
supposed to be zero so let's see we get
something close 0 again since this is an
approximation it won't give us the exact
value similarly we can use math dot cos
to find the value of a particular angle
if you want to find yeah if you want to
find the value of the sorry the cost of
a particular angle we can use the tan
function in case we wanted to find the
tan similarly we have the next set for
arc sine and the arcosines of the
certain of angles so to use to find the
arc sign for example we would use a DOT
sign I mean sorry a sign for R cosine we
would use this and for r10 we would use
this the next set would be hyperbolic
functions again hyperbolic functions are
basically the sine and the cosine and
the time calculated not circles but on
hyperbolas again the details don't have
to be you don't have to know the details
you just should you should know that if
you wanted to say for example find out
the hyperbolic sign of n and a of an
angle we would use math dot sine H and
we would pass what we wanted between
this similarly if we wanted to find the
cosine it would be cos H tan it would be
tan H and if we wanted to find the
inverse of the hyperbolic inverse we
what we would do is what we would do is
use a so we would use a tan H if you
wanted to find the hyperbolic inverse uh
of sine we would use a sine H and
similarly for cos it would be cos a COS
H so this concludes our video on the
math module in Python and some of the
math functions surrounding this so the
basic uh syntax if you will for a if
statement in Python consists of the
keyword if followed by an expression as
you can see from this pictorial uh if
there's an if statement there is a
expression uh there is this a block of
code which if you can actually see is
slightly indented to the rest of the
code and then we have the rest of the
the rest of our code after that so what
we're looking at is this so this is our
if statement block
um now let's let's break this down so
what is this expression that we are
speaking of uh an expression in this
context is a Boolean expression which
evaluates to a true or false statement
so when we are speaking about the if
statement we have an expression and if
this expression evaluates to true then
we execute everything below the if
statement otherwise we skip that portion
as you can see if this statement is true
we execute this statement or these
statement blocks uh otherwise if it's
false we move on to the next the next
statement block or the beginning of a
new statement uh so let's look at an
example to further understand this let's
take this if statement over here as you
can see in this if statement I have this
expression 50 greater than 30 so what
python is going to do now is it's going
to check whether 50 is greater than 30
and it's going to check in a Boolean
context a if this is true then we can
move on to the next portion which is
this but if it is false then we will
skip this so let's see what this uh what
happens over here so since we know that
50 is indeed greater than 30 this is a
true expression we move on to this block
of code which is saying that print 50 is
indeed a larger number than 30. so let's
see if this actually gets printed so as
you can see we get this uh the result
which is this is a true statement and we
get our print statement getting executed
what if we give a false expression over
here so let's look at what happens if I
gave a false expression now I'm checking
if 50 is lesser than 30 which is a false
statement so if it's a false statement
we do not move on to this portion of our
if statement block and we we directly in
fact we directly skip so if I have to
execute this you will see nothing gets
executed in in fact my print statement
is just not executed because we never
entered this because our expression over
here was indeed false so yeah this is
how a basic if statement block looks
like in Python and this is how the uh
how we move on to how we check for the
true the truth truthfulness or the
falseness of a particular expression in
the if statement so moving on
um let's move on to the topic of
indentation in in Python so as you can
see this uh this if statement is an
example of a control structure so
without moving without defining a what a
construct control structure is uh in
detail control structures consists of
these conditionals or Loops or
iterations if you will so all of these
control structures involve heavy
indentation so what does an indentation
mean well what if I gave you an example
say I gave you some variable called H
and I wrote 20 over here now if I give
you an if statement saying if age is
greater than 10 now uh it's very
important to note that when I'm finding
an if statement I need this colon
otherwise this if statement is not
defined so this colon is important
anyways so now I'm checking this
expression if age is greater than 10.
now what is this what happens if H is
greater than 10 now what if I want
python to do something only if age is
greater than 10 well how do I tell
python that there is a piece of code or
a section of code that I want executed
only if this condition is met well this
is where indentation comes into play so
if I want say if I want this line this
person is an adult again this is some
random line where I'm assuming age is
pertaining to this adult all right or
this person so if I have uh this
variable age where I write this number
20 which denotes the age of some person
and I'm doing a check if age is greater
than 10 actually let's be specific here
well the adult age for most people is 18
in most countries so let's see if age is
greater than 18. now if I'm doing this
check uh I want to print this statement
only if this person is a person's age is
above 20 above 18 so how do I tell
python that I only want this statement
to be uh executed only during this if
this condition is met well this is where
indentation comes into play and as you
can see exactly as you can see uh this
part this portion of the code is
slightly indented compared to the if
statement so when this condition is met
then only do we move on to this if this
condition is not met we move on to
whatever the next section of code will
be like whatever whatever code that we
have after this if statement so let's
see so this since this condition is
actually met as you can see this print
statement is actually executed so this
is the importance of indentation now we
will see uh in as we move as we learn
more about if statements and else
statements and alif statements how
indentation plays a key role in defining
what we want as an output when a certain
condition is met all right so for now
it's very important to understand that
this is how indentation is used in
Python in other languages we might use
uh we probably don't use indentation in
fact popular language the C language
does not use indentation at all but some
languages and python in probably the
trademark language for indentation and
programming so you might say that so
different people have different opinions
on an indentation the general consensus
is that indentation helps make the code
look very presentable and very readable
and this actually is one one of the
facets of Python Programming is the
indentation and the easy readability of
it anyways moving on so what if we have
um multiple conditions in our code or if
in our if statement block that we want
to see so let's create this list or
let's actually just copy this example
that I have written over here as you can
see what I am doing in this piece of
code is I have a list X where I have
this integer 50 I have two strings cat
and apple now I want to check a bunch of
things so I want to check if 60 is an X
and I also want to check if the string
cat is an X and I want a final sort of
like if none of these conditions are met
I want something to happen so how do we
do that well we start off our state our
if statement block with the standard if
keyword all right now if we have one
more condition that we want met then we
can use the L if which is kind of a
short form for else if uh so we use the
L if keyword so it so what this python
uh what python reads is it checks this
condition then it will check this
condition and then finally we have this
else keyword and else is a keyword used
in our block to tell python that if none
of our earlier Expressions have been
true then do what is in the uh there
that is within the else keyword that is
indented within the else keyword so
again we don't pass an expression for
else because else is only we only Reach
This LL statement in case all of the
earlier conditions have not been met or
have uh come to be false and not true so
let's look at uh this particular code
example so we have a list of 50 cat and
apple and um my first expression that
I'm checking is uh is 60 in X so this is
how we check actually so if 60 and X
should be read as is 60 in the list X so
is this 16 the licks list X well
actually no we don't have the object 60
so this part is not executed we move on
to the next condition is the string cat
in X well actually it is uh the string
cat is indeed in X so we move on to this
statement block which is within the
condition that is met which is print cat
is in list X and you will see that none
of the other statement blocks will be
executed because we have met our
condition over here so if I execute this
as you can see that the print statement
cat is in this text is what is actually
executed and we do not execute this
obviously because it is false and we do
not even check or we do not even move on
to the statement because well we have a
condition mat over here so it's a one
thing that is important to note is that
we can use as many alif statements to
check for as many conditions that we we
want to check for but it's very
important that we only use and if we are
using that we only use one else
statement and only at the end end of our
block okay so moving on now I'm going to
show you a very neat example about how
python actually does its uh these
condition checkings so it's very
important to note that once a condition
is met none of the other conditions are
even checked for so
um we do not even consider the next
statements and we directly leave this if
statement block so let's look at this
example over here now in this example
that I have over here is where I've
stored the string cat in X now I have
three uh I have three conditions that
I'm checking I'm checking is 50 greater
than 60. I am checking if the value of x
is indeed cat and I'm checking I'm some
random expression 1 divided by zero this
is not even a check this is literally
just checking if 1 divided by 0 is true
or false and as we know we cannot divide
anything by zero so let's see what
happens when I execute this statement
now typically if I wrote 1 divided by 0
python will throw me an error because 1
cannot be divided by 0 that is an error
error statement so let's see what
happens when I do this actually as you
can see I have a statement being printed
but I have no error even though I gave
it wrong I gave an error statement in 1
divided by zero well now you might ask
why is that so well it's simply because
I have actually never reached this
condition I have not even python is not
bothered looking at this because if you
actually see there is a condition
previous to this over here which is met
and which is true so we move on to this
block we execute this block and we
forget about the rest of the code so we
don't actually get to this error
statement which is an interesting thing
and which is an example that I have
shown uh to show you that once a
condition is met in an if statement
block we do not look at any of the
further conditions that are being
checked okay so finally
um I have one one small topic that I
would like to share with you is the
conditional expressions or the pythons
ternary operator now this is slightly
different to the the if statement that
we have talked about up until now in the
sense that it is not a control structure
so what this actually is is more of an
operator that defines some expression so
let's see what I am trying to say over
here so as you can see over here
highlighted is the Syntax for what I'm
trying to talk about this ternary
operator so let's look at this example
and let's see what I'm trying to do over
here so I have this variable age all
right and this age is 26 now X now just
just read this statement X is equal to
adult if age is greater than 18 else
child now I could have done an elaborate
control structure with an if statement
then an indentation within that if
statement and then I could have written
else and then another indentation and I
would have written another statement
over there but instead of that I have
used this operator to assign a
particular value to the variable X and
this uh what value I'm assigning to X
depends on if this condition is 2 or 5
false so as you can see the condition
says is age 18 greater than 18. so if
this is true then I assign this
particular string if it is false then I
go on to the else statement and I assign
this so since age 26 is greater than 18
I should assign the string adult to X
and as you can see if I execute this and
check what is an X you can see adult is
indeed in X so this is a very neat a
very needable readable and a very um
it's a it's probably a more it's it's a
better looking way uh to perform simple
else uh Sim simple if and else
statements where you don't want to
create a whole um if stay if if else
statement control structure block so
yeah this was the ternary operator
finally we Let's uh we we make a short
note on the pass statement uh in Python
so the path statement or the past
keyword is a a place where it is is a
placeholder of sorts so what if I had an
if statement and I'm writing a piece of
code but I don't know what to do with
this if statement so if if a statement
is correct if a statement is true but I
don't know what to do if this statement
was true how do I tell python well let's
just keep it a hold for now and I might
put something into this block later in
the future well I would use the pass
statement so if I had this say this some
condition again so I'm checking age is
greater than 18 but I don't know what to
do with this I would just simply use
this past statement and this basically
does nothing uh it it's a way to it's
like a way to create a placeholder where
maybe in the future I might have I might
write some sort of a say a print
statement or some sort of a different
function or something else within this
indentation so but in the meantime like
currently I don't have anything to place
over here so I just leave it with a pass
statement so this is a way where you can
use a pass statement in if and else
statement or if an else control
structures so yeah this was a basic or
the an introduction into conditional
statements and the control structure of
FNL statements in Python an iteration is
uh executing the same block of code over
and over potentially many times a
programming structure that implements an
iteration is called a loop now in
programming we have two types of
iterations definite and indefinite
iterations and in this example we will
be speaking about indefinite iterations
in definite iterations in Python is the
while loop where we use the while
keyword to Define an indefinite
iteration so let's look at the basic
syntax as you can see this is the basic
syntax where we have the while keyword
followed by an expression and again the
colon and below that is something
indented again we encounter indentations
just like NFL statements uh a set of
statements where what happens here is
following the while keyword we have this
expression where this expression is
evaluated in a Boolean context again we
check if this expression evaluates true
or false and if it is true we execute
all the statements or the statement
block that is entered below this file
statement this is another example of
control structure much like FNS hidden
blocks where we use a lot of indentation
so let's look at a basic example now of
while loop so let's copy this example
and let's see what this does so I have a
variable n where I am assigning it a
value 0. this is called an initializing
process and it's very important to note
that most while Loops consist of an
expression which contains a variable a
control variable uh which is usually
initialized prior to starting the loop
and then this control variable is
typically very modified somewhere within
the main Loop body so in this case my
control variable is n and I am
initializing it by assigning it the
value 0 so let's move into the loop now
so the loop has this wire keyword as you
can see followed by a an expression n
lesser than or equal to 5. now what this
is is an expression which is going to
check if it's true false is n lesser
than or equal to 5 and as long as this
expression is true we will continue
doing whatever is indented below this y
statement and what is below this y
statement is a print statement first of
all which says value of n is and it
basically prints a value of n in that
particular iteration and as you can see
this uh compound assignment where we add
the value of n by 1 and we assign it
back to n so what this is uh let's see
what this does actually let's execute
this and see what this does important to
note the value of n again is initialized
at zero so this while while loop will
keep going on until the value of n
remains lesser than or equal to 5. so as
you can see I have the execution of this
uh particular block of code or this
while loop where I get the multiple
different iterations of this print
statement that you can see here the
first iteration it says value of n is 0
then it's the value of n is 1. what I'm
doing is I am writing I am assigned I am
writing uh the value of n multiple times
and each time the value of n is written
over here based on what iteration it is
so what is happening actually is uh the
initially the value of n is 0 and I
print the statement value of n is 0. now
I add the value of what is In N by 1 so
now what is the value of n so again we
do this check so after this first
iteration we come back or like once this
whole code block of code is executed we
again come back to this expression and
we again check if the statement is true
so now that the value of n is actually 1
if this statement is still true so again
we execute this and that you can see
over here value of n is 1. now again we
add the value of n by 1 and again we go
back here once this uh this block is
executed and we check if this statement
is true again and as you can see the
value of n when it's 2 is still making
sure that this expression is true and
this keeps happening until the value of
n is greater than 5. so once the value
of n becomes 6 this condition is no
longer met and finally we do not execute
the statement because this expression
evaluates to false and we do not do this
anymore and we finally leave our while
loop so let's check what the value of n
is just to confirm this as you can see
the value of n is indeed 6 and that is
why we have left this while loop over
here so this is an example of a basic
while loop where we check for this uh an
expression if it evaluates to true we
evaluate everything within it once this
is done we go back and we evaluate this
expression again if it is again true we
again go back into whatever is indented
within it and we keep doing this until
the expression gives us false and
interestingly we don't we don't
necessarily have to Define these control
variables always we can actually use uh
iterables and we will learn about
iterables actually in a future video but
we can use it builds an example of an
iterable is uh the list so let's look at
this list and let's look at this whole
block from right so I created this list
a which contains five objects one two
three four and five all integer objects
and I have another variable X where I
store the integer one now I'm this while
statement now it might look confusing
now it's it says it says while a now
what is a well a is not uh your typical
expression where you're making sure if
some condition is being met or not but
this the way you read this is while a
exists so in the context of a list as
long as a which is a list contains
objects within it a is true if it does
not have any objects within it a is
false so while a basically what it means
is while a has objects within it and if
it does have objects within it or as
long as it does we continue executing
whatever is indented within this while
statement and this y statement is a
print statement again we uh do like we
we have this value X where we um we're
doing this is this we're printing this
is iteration number and we pass X so the
first iteration obviously pass X is
equal to 1 and then we add X by 1 and
then the second iteration should pass
this iteration number two and then so on
and finally we have another statement
within this block called the a called
the uh pop statement where we're popping
the elements of a now as if you would
have seen the list the video on list the
pop statement removes the rightmost
value uh from a list so if I do a DOT
pop initially it will remove 5 from this
list and I will have the rest of them
again if I do pop it will remove 4 from
this list and then you will have the
rest of these so let's actually see
we'll actually check what's left in this
list each time we do this pop statement
so that I'll also print the list a it's
uh during each iteration and let's see
what happens over here as you can see
what is happening out here is while a or
while a has elements we are going to
continue doing this y statement whatever
is within it so in the first iteration
obviously we have all of it uh and it is
iteration number one and as you can see
the list contains everything then I pop
it then iteration number two it again
has elements but it has lost its most
rightmost element and this keeps on
happening until the list finally has no
elements left and once element or
invents a list has no elements left we
this expression while a evaluates to
false and we do not execute this anymore
and we leave the while low and again
let's check what is an A A should have
no elements as you can see it's an empty
list when I check what's in a it's an
empty list and that is why while a
return near false and we do not print
any further so this is an example of
using a wire statement using lists and
of course the next topic would be
discussing nested while loops and this
is a broad topic what I mean by this is
that when when I'm saying nested while
Loops I'm actually talking about nested
control structures so we can have while
Loops within while Loops not only that
we can have FNS statements within while
Loops we can have while Loops within if
and else statements and we can have FNL
statements with an FNL statements so if
you think of all of these Loops uh and
we will even speak our for Loops in the
in the in in a in another video for
Loops again a type of control structure
so all of these are control structures
while Loops are control structures for
Loops or control structures if and as
statements are control structures all of
these are control structures and nesting
can happen within them and it does not
matter uh which is the like the parent
of the nest and then the child of the
nest we can have a while loop within an
if and else statement you can have for
Loops within a while loop all of this is
valid in Python and uh it's one of the
one of the great features of python that
is very flexible in this way so let's
look at an example where I have a while
loop within another while loop so I am
copying this piece of code where I have
this list one two three four five and
another list first and second now my
first while loop I print I print what is
pop from a so I take a then I pop the
zeroth index so base basically from the
left hand side and I print what is that
all right and then I have another while
loop where I have this list B and I'm
doing the same thing but this while loop
is within the first while loop and let's
see what happens out here so as you can
see my first uh my first iteration of
this parent while loop causes me to pop
what is the first element which is one
then I do these while loops and this is
completely executed and only then do I
go back to this first one and then I
come back and do all of this again then
I go back to this one and then I come
back and do all of this again and that's
why you can see this repetition so I
have this first iteration and then I do
the second while loop then I have the
second iteration and then I do the
second while when I keep doing this and
this is an example of a nested while
loop okay so our next Topic in this
section this video would be break and
continue statements now break in
continue statements are ways to abruptly
end iterations uh in in a particular
Loop you can use break in continue
statements not only in while those but
you can use it and also in for Loops so
let's look at how we use it in while
loops and let's look at what we mean by
breaking continuous statements first of
all well the break statement terminates
the loop entirely so once the break
statement is found the the complete
while loop that we are using is
completely terminated and the continuous
statement on the other hand terminates
only the current Loop iteration and it
goes back to the beginning or the
expression and it checks whether the
expression or the the controlling
expression is again re-evaluated and it
is checked whether the loop will execute
again or terminate this pictorial that
you can see here actually emphasizes or
it shows the difference between break
and continue so I have this while loop
and I have an expression all right I
have a bunch of statements and I have a
break command over here and I have a
continue command over here so if I
encounter the break command it will not
execute any of this in fact it will not
execute this wire statement at all and
it will move on to the next piece of
code that we have but a continuous
statement if a continuous statement is
encountered in a while loop will not
completely break away but it will not uh
it will not execute the the rest of the
statements in that iteration only these
two but it will go back here it will
check this expression again and again we
will do this all over again so this is
this small uh difference between the
break and continue statements but both
are used to abruptly end an iteration in
a loop so let's look at an example of
how we use the break statement so I will
use this example where I have again I
have initialized some controlling
variable n to 0 my first Loop will check
whether n is less than equal to 5 if
this is true then I will print this
statement then I will what I'm doing
over here is I am incrementing it by one
now in my previous my earlier example
using a similar uh using the similar
example I had no like this this part was
not there so what you got was I was
printing the value of n so it was
printing as like value of n is 1 I mean
0 and then one and then two and then
three four and five but over here I've
included a small I've nested an if
statement and within that I put a break
statement and this if statement is
checking if if n is equal to equal to 2
so once n is 2 I move on to this and I
do the break statement so let's see what
happens now as you can see once so when
I have executed this I don't get the
whole value of n is 0 and then one and
then two three four five I I stop at one
and that is because once n is equal to 2
I actually do not execute this while
loop again I do not go back and execute
print value of n is 2 now in fact I
break from this whole while loop and my
while loop terminal is right then and
there and that's why you only get these
two iterations value of n is 0 and then
value of n is one okay so now I'm going
to show you a neat example of what
happens or what is the difference
between a break and a continuous
statement okay so let's uh go back to
our initial example where we have
printing this value of n is 0 1 2 3 4
and so on but I have added one more
statement where I print hello at each
iteration so let's see what happens when
I do this as you can see it will print
hello after each of whatever I was doing
already now let's introduce our break
statement first of all so when I do
break well let's go back to this if
statement if is if we check this
condition then we break let's see what
happens now as you can see something
interesting has happened where we have
this first iteration completely being
executed but the second iteration kind
of stops where there's no hello and that
is because we have broken from this
while loop before the second iterations
hello was printed let's see the
difference between a break and continue
now so now I have this continuous
statement instead of a break let's see
what happens here as you can see it
seems familiar to our first example
where we do not have any break or
continue but there is a small difference
that I want you to catch and that is
very important about this continue uh
statement so as you can see the first
iteration has value of n is 0 and then
hello and value of n is 1 but there is
no hello and this is because this is
because once this condition is actually
met we do not move on to this statement
but we go back to this expression and we
will evaluate this expression and then
once we evaluate this expression again
and it's found to be correct we do
everything the same again when we print
hello but except for that one step where
this if statement was met and we did
continue and this following statement
was not executed and that happens only
for one iteration and that is when n is
equal to equal to 2 and as you can see
that is what happens over here in one of
the iterations we may say hello and that
is the difference of the continue
statement between uh there is a
difference of the continuous statement
with the break statement so this
concludes it for our video on indefinite
iterations I hope you learned about
while loops and definite iterations so
starting off we know that there are two
types of iterations in programming a
definite and indefinite we have already
covered indefinite iterations in the
form of while Loops definite iterations
on the other hand are done using the
keyword for and the basic syntax or the
standard Syntax for a basic for Loop in
Python is as you can see over here we
have this four keyword we have some
variable we have the in keyword and we
have this iterable and we of course
Define this control structure with the
colon and then indented we have this
statement block so once this for Loop
has started we execute all of these
statements within the statement block as
part of the for Loop iteration so yeah
let's uh now let's to understand like
how for loops work uh exactly let's look
at the concept or meaning behind what we
call iterables and iterators so so think
of it in a step why manner all right so
we in Python we have different objects
that can be used as iterables and an
iterable is basically some object that
it's a collection of other objects so
you know think of your lists uh think of
dictionaries and sets so all of these
are essentially collections of objects
so once we have these collection of
objects we can create an iterator out of
it how do we do that is we use the iter
function so for example if I passed this
list a if I pass this list a through the
iter function and I store it in some
variable either underscore a and I see
what is it underscore a it is actually a
list iterator at some random memory
location which we don't really care
about similarly if I gave a tuple and I
did the same thing I will create a tuple
iterator and in the left if you can see
over here I've done the exact same
functions with sets and dictionaries as
well so I'm creating iterators out of
these
iterables so as to speak uh now what is
an iterator well an iterator is an
object that yields values successively
so if my list contained five values or
five objects an iterator of this list
will yield these values uh one after the
other and that is kind of how or that is
the basis for which we do we create
Loops let's see what we exactly mean
using this uh using another function
that we call the next function so the
next function keeps moving from object
to object within an iterator so since
I've created this list iterator let's
just do it once again so as you can see
I've created this list iterator
underscore a now with this item
underscore a what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use this next function what
next function does is starting from the
leftmost object within this iterator I
will keep yielding or keep producing the
values so let's let's just see what
happens when you next iter when I do
next for this particular variable it
gives me this object first now let's see
what happens when I do it again
now it gives me the object second what
if I did it again it gives me third now
if I kept doing this it will keep giving
me the different objects that were
initially stored in a that is first and
then second third fourth and fifth one
after the other so let's actually
perform that now I get fourth now I get
fifth now an actual question is now that
I've exhausted all of these values what
will happen if I perform the next
function again now let's see what
happens I get a an error or and this
error is the stop iteration function
error which basically is telling me look
you have exhausted all of the objects
that were initially present in this list
a and you cannot you cannot keep doing
the next next function anymore you
cannot keep going further so yeah so
this is what the next function does when
it comes to the concept of iterators all
right so now we've learned two things
what is an iterator and what is the how
do we create an iterator out of
different collections of objects like a
list or a tuple and we've also learned
how to use the next function now let's
uh move or let's come back to our for
Loop that we started off this video with
so our for loop again let's consider our
for Loop over here
as you can see some for loop with the
objects again one two three four and
five all right this is a list now I'm
going to do for X in a print X and let's
try to see what happens when we do this
okay as you can see when I have executed
this it gives me one two three four and
five so I have first of all let's look
at this for loop I in this for loop I
Define a new variable X and then I say
for X in a print X and what's happening
well in each iteration I am printing
whatever the value of x is at present so
in the first iteration it is the first
object one in the second iteration it is
the second object two then three four
five and then finally uh on its own like
uh this for Loop knows that okay now
once I have exhausted all of the objects
within my iterator I can stop doing this
for Loop and I can move on with the rest
of the code all right so think of it
like a three-step process a for Loop in
Python the first step is it calls an
iter function to obtain an iterator for
whatever we pass over here this iterable
second step it calls the next function
repeatedly in each iteration all right
to keep getting the next item from the
iterator so it gets one then it calls
next then it gets two then it calls next
and it gets three and then four and then
five and so on and then finally the
third step is determination step is when
after we do the final next where we get
this error as you can see the stop
iteration error or exception finally
this tells the for Loop function or the
for Loop that okay we have reached the
end of our definite iteration or the end
of our definite for Loop and this is
where we must terminate our Loop and
then continue with the rest of the code
all right so this is how a for Loop
Works in Python now it's very important
to note that whatever we have discussed
when it came to while Loops such as
nesting of while loops and nesting of
other control structures is also
applicable in the case of for Loops so
if I had a for Loop in another for Loop
that is perfectly fine if I had a while
within a for Loop that is perfectly fine
so all of these are valid statement
blocks that we can do and again for Loop
is another control structure and so we
must follow the concept of indentation
when it comes to writing our statement
blocks within a for Loop okay so now I'm
going to speak about in specific I'm
going to speak about the this uh
something called the range function that
is uh quite you could say it's used
definitely it's used in other areas of
programming but it's widely used in
Python uh I mean I mean the for Loop in
Python uh what I mean by this is that um
Range this range function is very
important for the for Loop and we will
see why okay so let's look at one of the
examples of using the range function so
what does the range function do is if I
give range 5 let's see what it does it
gives me range 0 to 5. what this
basically tells me is that this will
create an iterator that contains uh
integers from 0 to 5 so it will contain
the object 0 1 2 3 4 and 5 and we can
use this as an iterator so let's let's
look at this I have Range Five let's
store this in X okay now let's do a type
just to see what happens when we do Type
X it should give me the type of range as
you can see and this is a type of an
iterator in Python now let's see what
happens when I do for I in X print I
okay let's see what happens as you can
see it prints the number zero one two
three four an important caveat when it
comes to the range function is when we
say range 5 it creates an iterator from
0 to 5 but it contains the objects 0 1 2
3 and 4 only it does not contain the
object 5 itself okay this is something
that is very important to so once again
I created I use this range function to
create an iterator from if iterator 5
objects from 0 to 4 0 1 2 3 and 4. I use
that in my for Loop and that's what that
is what you are seeing here now let's
use this range function in the context
of something else for example let's see
so I had my earlier list a right look at
my list a here
so you can see place a contains these
one two three four five five objects
okay let's see what length of a is
length of a is five okay uh let's use
the range function on top of the length
of this list a and this is uh like I
can't show you an example right now
without any context but this uh this
form of using a for Loop is used is
widely used in Python Programming you
will use it so much in data science you
will use so much in machine learning and
AI I cannot tell you uh this is so this
is a very important like sort of for
Loop expression so you have four let's
say I in range Len a let's see what's
going on here first I create first I do
length of a that gives me 5 then into
range of 5 that creates an iterator
between 0 and 4 right when you do Range
Five it gives you an iterator of zero
one two three and four as we saw earlier
and this is what we're doing over here
we have created an iterator out of the
length of a list now when I do print I
it should give me again one two three
four zero one two three four of course
so as you can see here it will give me 0
1 2 3 4 and this is a very neat way of
using the range function on top of the
length of a particular collection of
objects in this case we're using the
list a this is something that you will
use a lot so I I would recommend that
you get used to this form of creating a
for loop as well using the range
function also of course
um there are the you can use break and
continue statements as you have in the
case of while Loops uh exactly this it
works exactly the same in the case of
for Loops wherein the break statement
will abruptly stop the for Loop
completely and we will move on to the
next piece of code whereas the continue
statement will break that particular
iteration and then we will resume with
the next iteration so yeah that was
breaking continue statements in for
Loops finally I would like to show you
something about uh how to use
dictionaries as an iterator or or as an
iterable when it comes to for Loops so
let's create our dictionary let's go we
have a dictionary already here in fact
create this dictionary again we'll store
it in a okay so I created this
dictionary a all right so I have
dictionary a uh what I'm going to do is
I'm going to pass it through the iter
function as you can see and now I'm
going to just for the sake of showing
you it will show I'll show you that it
is actually an iterator of type of a
specific key iterator type all right so
now let's uh let's do something on this
so as you can see in the dictionary I
have the key first that has the value
one I have the key second that has the
value 2 I have the key third that has a
value three and then fourth for four
fifth for five now a good question would
be when I do iteration or when I do a
for loop on top of this a well what is
it going to pick up is it going to pick
up first uh is it going to pick up the
keys like these or is it going to pick
up the values or is it going to go one
by one key and then value and then key
in the subsequent value uh let's see
what actually happens let's do 4 I in
iter underscore a print I let's see what
what is The iterations Happening upon
using this so as you can see we're using
the keys so by default when we do this
when we perform when we create an
iterator out of a dictionary we use only
the keys as our iterator elements all
right iterator values but of course like
if you wanted to use values all you
would have to do is pass a DOT values
over here and if you remember from a
dictionary video this uh a DOT values
gives us a list of or it it gives us the
essentially a list of the values in our
dictionary so when we pass this to the
iterator uh iter function and we create
an iterator out of it let's see what
happens over here now let's see what is
ETA underscore a you can actually see
it's now the dict value iterator at a
particular memory location so it's not
the dict key as we saw earlier it's a
dict value iterator so now that we have
this by dictionary value iterator now
let's print what are our iterator
elements and as you can see now we are
printing values and not um the keys so
this is how to this this is basically
two different ways of iterating through
a dictionary one through keys and one
through values so this concludes it for
our video on definite iterations in
Python I hope in this video you
understood and you learned about the
concept of iterables and iterators and
the different functions associated with
it and how exactly the for Loop function
Works uh in Python so let's first revise
some of the concepts of an if statement
so basic if statement can be something
like this we have a small condition
where we are checking if a variable X is
greater than 5 or not and if it is
greater than x we print a statement over
here so if this condition is met we
print this statement else we move to the
statement log now our variable X has
value 5 now since X is not greater than
5 what this will do is it will check
this statement and since this will be
false we skip this statement block and
move on to this statement so as you can
see here similarly we can do something
where we're checking multiple statements
we use the L if statement in such a case
so now in this block we are checking in
one of the one of the conditions we're
checking is if x is equal to 5 or if x
is greater than 5 and then finally if
both of these conditions are not met we
say else and we print whatever or we do
whatever is in this particular statement
block which is a simple print statement
so as you can see X is indeed good is
equal to 5 so this is the block that
will get executed as you can see here
now another example are nested if
statements so nested if else statements
are if else statements within if else
statements so let's look at an example
as you can see here we have a string
stored in a variable called orange
quality and the string is fresh now we
have an integer or a float in this case
4.0 stored in Orange price now our first
statement is checking whether orange
quality the variable orange quality is
it equal to the string fresh now within
that if the statement or if this
condition is met we do another check
where we're checking what is the price
is it lesser than 5 if it is V2 this
block else we execute this block finally
if our initial uh statement our initial
condition is not met we move on to this
else block now when I execute this what
should happen is I will enter this block
because this is true and finally I will
enter this block because this condition
is also true so I should have this
printed I will buy five dozens as you
can see here now let's move on to our
main exercise for this video so this was
all just the revision now we're going to
use some or all of these Concepts in a
sample project or a sample exercise to
for your further practice so in this
exercise what we're going to do is we're
going to request the user to enter a
number between 1 and 20 and our our code
is going to check whether this number
entered is an even number or an odd
number so as you can see there are two
sets of checks that we're going to do in
this code the first check is going to be
whether the number that is entered is
between 1 and 20 or not and if it is not
we have to say it's an invalid number
but if it is entered between 1 and 20 we
have to move on to the further checks
which is whether it is an even or an odd
number so let's see how we do that so in
this piece of code what we start with is
a print statement saying please enter a
number between 1 and 20 and then we add
an input command this input command will
open a box where we can enter whatever
number that we want to enter now we use
this int keyword to make sure that
whatever we have entered into the input
box is stored as a int data type in the
enter num variable once we do that our
first if statement is going to check
whether the entered number is greater
than or equal to 1 or less than equal to
20. sorry and less than equal to 20. so
both of these conditions have to be met
if this condition is true then we have a
valid input and this statement is
printed that we have entered a valid
number and then we move on to the rest
of the statement block within this if
statement which is another set of if and
else if statements if our number is not
between 120 we move to this block and
this block prints that we have entered
in invalid number now once we have say
entered a valid number we move on to
this block this is in if else if LF
statement block now what this block is
checking is whether the entered number
is an even number or not now as we know
an even number is divisible by 2 when we
the remainder 0 when divided by 2. so
this is what this check is doing if this
check is true that means our number is
even and we get printed that our number
is even the other other check or the
other uh if statement is checking
whether it's an odd number and that
means when we divide by 2 we should get
the remainder 1 as you can see here and
we get printed your number is odd so
let's execute this and see what happens
when we enter a number now it's asking
me to enter a number let's say I enter
17.
now that I've entered 17 as you can see
it's a valid number that I have entered
and the code is telling me that my
number is indeed odd let's look at some
other what if I entered something else
here let's say if I enter 16 now since
it's an even number as you can see 16 is
also a valid number as it's between 1
and 20 and my number is even and the
code checks for that let's see if what
happens when I enter an invalid number
let's say 25 into 25 as you can see it
says I have entered invalid number and
in this case what has happened is this
condition itself is not met and I have
moved on to this statement block so to
give you a breakdown as to how our code
has executed this let me show you an
example for the number say 9 when I
enter nine the first check that happens
of course is this check whether it's a
valid number or not and since it is
between 1 and 20 we move on to this
block and in this block it's checking
whether our numbers divisible by 2 or
not and since it is not it will remain
it will leave a remainder 1 and we
execute this block it says our print our
number is Odd as you can see here so
this was a brief recap into the if
statement and if else statements
necessary file statements we also saw an
exercise where we used nested FL
statements so our first example will be
where we calculate the factorial of a
number in this example as you can see
here we are first going to ask the user
to enter a particular number for us now
this number is supposed to be an integer
once we have this integer we store it to
a variable called number now we have
this you can say this variable called
fac which stores 1 and you we will see
how we are using it later now we know
that the factorial of 0 is 1 that's how
it's just defined so we have an if
statement checking whether our entered
number is 0 and if it is 0 we say that
the result is 1 or the factorial is one
however if we enter a number that is
greater than 0 we must calculate the
factorial for this number and that is
what we are going to do in this else
statement block over here now in this
else statement block we have a while
loop in this while loop the condition is
checking while number is greater than or
equal to 1. so as long as this condition
is true everything within that while
loop will be executed so as long as
number is greater than equal to 1 we are
going to execute these two lines now
what do these two lines do let us see so
the first line takes the variable fac
where we had the number one stored and
we are going to store FEC times number
into it number being the number that we
have inputted so in case for example we
still we entered 8 then what this will
do this line will do is 1 into 8 and it
will store that back into fac now once
that is done we move on to the next line
where we are decrementing the number
variable by one so if we have stored 8
or we have entered 8 into our input it
will become 7. now as we know 7 is still
greater than equal to 1 so this
condition is still being met and then we
do this process again where we are going
to multiply fac this time fac stores the
value 8 and we multiply it times the new
number which is 7 now so we do 8 into 7
and then again we decrement this uh also
one three to eight into seven we store
it back into fac and we keep doing this
where we keep multiplying 8 times 7 and
then we decrement the number variable uh
by one and then we check this condition
again so what ends up happening is we
are going to keep doing 8 into 7 into 6
into 5 into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1 and
once we are at 1 again when we do this
document operation the number variable
we store the value is 0 and then this
condition will no longer be met so
number will be 0 and this condition will
be false and we can move out of this
while low then finally we store the
result into a variable called result
which stores the result of 8 into 7 into
6 into 5 and to 4 into 3 into 2 into 1
this is of course if we did enter 8 when
we were asked to give an input so let's
see this
um in real time once we execute this so
I'm executing this the first thing it
asks me is to enter a number so let's
say I enter my number 8 as I was
speaking about eight all right now that
I have entered 8 as you can see the
result that it gives me is factorial of
8 is 40320 which is correct and you can
check this for yourself where it will
show you
um 8 times 7 or 8 factorial is basically
this this number okay so now in our next
example we will be looking at how we can
generate Fibonacci numbers for this
example we will be using bunch of if and
else if statements along with a while
loop so let's look at this piece of code
where we are actually doing this so as
you can see the first part of the code
is basically an input statement asking
us how many Fibonacci numbers we would
like to generate and then the user would
be asked to given an input which is
stored as an INT into a variable count
now in this if a statement the first if
statement checks whether what we have
entered is 0 in which case we just store
an empty array in the variable called
FIB next if our entered integer is 1 we
just store the value 1 in this array
called FIB if our enter number is 2 we
store 1 and 1 in the array FIB all of
these are different sets of Fibonacci
sequences this obviously an empty an
empty array shows that well there is no
numbers to be generated in this sequence
if we have one we just print the first
number of the Fibonacci sequence which
is one itself if it is 2 we print the
first two numbers which is one and one
now the actual calculations happen when
we say we want a Fibonacci sequence for
more than two numbers now in that case
we move on to this block in this
statement block we initialize the FIB
variable with the first two Fibonacci
numbers one and one and we store in this
very in this array now we are going to
do a while loop within this and in this
while loop we're going to keep executing
this statement block as long as this
condition is met or this condition is
true and what this condition is is it's
checking this variable I which we have
initialized as 1 over here and we are
going to check whether that is lesser
than count minus 1 count being the
number that we have been asked to input
if the statement is true and as long as
this statement is true we will be
executing this statement block which is
basically us appending this expression
into the array FIB now what this
expression is is basically it's going to
keep adding so each subsequent numbers
and we're going to store each subsequent
numbers back into the array Fib so in
this case if you see the fourth the
first step will do is it will take the
value at the first portion of the array
film and it will add it to the value at
the 0th position of the array fib and
both of these values since they are 1
and 1 when we add them we get 2 and we
append that to Fib so now our FIB will
look like 1 comma 1 comma two then we
increment this by 1 and what we do is we
do the same process again so in the next
step what will be what we would do is we
would do 2 plus 1 so we would get three
now this would keep going on until this
condition is met or basically until the
numbers that we actually want to
generate in our sequence so let's like
let's let's uh execute this and let's
see an example of what happens so it
asks me how many Fibonacci numbers I
would like to generate and I will say I
want the first let's say six Fibonacci
numbers so I execute this as you can see
this gives me the first six numbers in
the sequence which is one and one and
then 2 which is basically one plus one
and then three which is one plus two and
then five which is two plus three eight
which is three plus five so if we wanted
more numbers we would just enter over
here like say if you wanted the first 10
numbers it would give us the first 10
numbers in the sequence as you can see
here now in our next example what we are
going to do is we are going to write a
program which takes two digits that
represent the dimensions of an array for
example if we want a three by three
array we will enter three comma 3 and we
are going to generate a two dimensional
array in which each of the elements of
the array are basically the row times
the column position of that particular
element and what I mean by this is say
we have a position I comma J on the
array the value of the element at that
position would be I times J so for
example if I'm looking at something at
the third row and the fifth column or
say the third row and the third column
for example the value of the element
would be 3 times 3 and if I'm looking at
something at the second row and the
fourth column I am going to do 2 times
4. so let's uh let's see how we can do
this using Code so if you look to the
right over here I have a piece of code
where I'm going to uh in where it asks
me to input two numbers two integers to
represent the dimensions of my uh
example my sample array now once we have
done this we are going to store these uh
these dimensions in the inputs in in a
variable called input string so
obviously when we enter say 5 comma 5
that will be stored as an INT in this
particular string or this variable what
we want is we want five save a enter 5
comma five we want five as a separate
integer and the other five as another
separate integer and that is what we do
in this particular statement where we
are going to split up our input string
based on the comma separator and we're
going to store the first part of that
string into the 0th position of
Dimensions which is an array and the
next dimension in the first position in
this particular array now we are going
to store the number of rows as row
number and that is the zeroth position
of this array and we're going to store
the number of columns as the first
position of Dimensions or whatever we've
mentioned in the input so now we we have
this our results array called multi-list
which is basically what what our final
array is going to look like and we are
going to store into multi-list and in
this example we will be using for Loops
to do this or to create this particular
array so as you can see here our first
uh we have initialized our multi list
saying that we're going to have only
zeros in our sample array so initially
once we have initial this array all
multi list will contain is a say for
example we have inputted a five by five
array it will have basically a 5x5 array
with all elements as zero and that's
what this line does once we have done
this we are going to move on to the for
Loop portion where we are actually going
to create our array that we want so as
you can see we are our first for Loop is
going to say forward Row in range row
number so obviously uh range will
generate a an iterator which can be
iterated over and since it says range
row number and say our the number of
rows that we entered were five what it's
going to do is it's going to create an
iterator containing the value 0 1 2 3
and 4. so for row and range it will
basically basically row will take the
value 0 1 2 3 and 4. and a similar thing
is going to happen in this nested for
Loop which is within this where we're
going to again uh create a an iterator
using this range function and for the
column number once we have this we're
going to do this simple process of
multiplying the uh the value of the
element based on its position so if it's
at the position 3 comma 4 we are going
to store the value 3 times 4 into that
particular position of the array and
we're going to do this for every
position which is what happens in these
two for Loops we are going to first go
by each row and then within that we're
going to check each column and we're
going to perform these calculations and
finally we print our result so let's
look at an example now I'm going to say
I want a 3 by let's say a 2 by 4 Matrix
so let's see what the results will be
when I give this as uh so what I'm
saying is I want two rows and four
columns now as you can see here it might
not be very clear to you right now but
what you can see here is this is the
first row and this is the second row and
each row contains four columns so these
are the this is the my final array that
I get so what you can see here is this
is the zeroth position and the uh or you
can say this is the first row First
Column first row second column and since
python is zero based so this is actually
the zeroth row and this is the first row
so as you can see uh this this value
basically is zero times one this value
is zero times two zero times three zero
times four and over here it is one time
zero one times one one times two one
times three so similarly if I did for
example a five by five Matrix what you
will get is five rows now five rows and
five columns and for example like this
particular value is uh one two three or
zero one two three so zero one two three
and the First Column so this is three
times one
um if I took this value this is like the
fourth row for example fourth row times
the um zero one two three third column
so this would be four times three which
is twelve so and each value of this has
been generated in the similar process so
this is an example of how we can use for
Loops
um for a particular exercise that I have
shown you right now so this was it for
these particular examples into violin
for Loops uh I hope you found the two
examples on while loop in this one
example on for Loops uh helpful to you
and I hope it gave you further insight
into how we can use these types of Loops
in say different projects
hello everyone and welcome to another
video on Python Programming in this
video we will be covering a sort of a
project type of scenario which is
basically going to be a problem case for
you and uh it's going to be slightly
slightly difficult slightly tricky
um but what we're going to do is we're
going to tackle a particular problem and
we're going to what I'm going to do is
also show you a solution to that problem
so let's start with this so this
question that we have is
um we have this program that we have to
write where we compute the frequency of
words that exist in some input okay uh
the program should output after sorting
the key alphanumerically now this input
can be and it's basically a block of
text right so in our example we have for
example if this was our input right what
we want to see is
um
and an output which is basically saying
that uh the word python has appeared say
well in this example disappeared five
times and then the word read has
appeared one time and so on and so forth
like for each of these words we want to
see um how many times have they appeared
in this project particular block of text
so um let's look at a particular example
now where we have done this so let's um
let's see here
so first of all I'm going to create a
dictionary so why am I creating a
dictionary is because I'm going to use
each unique word as a key and the number
of times they have appeared in a block
of text as the value to that key so um
I'm going to use a sample string which
is basically this long string that you
can see here which is stored in line so
this large chunk of text is what we're
going to be analyzing
um so how are we going to do this it's
pretty simple so we have this now what
we want to do is
um when we find what we one way of
tackling this problem that we're going
to do here is we want to
um check word by word
um first of all we want to see if it's a
unique word and if this word is
um we've encountered it for the first
time then we need to store a new key
here in our dictionary called frequent
table or frequency table
um and if it has already if there is a
key already with that particular name
then we just want to increment the count
or the value by one so let's see how we
do this over here so if you can see in
my this the solution is as simple as
this but if you see what's happening
it's basically what uh what it's doing
is we're splitting up this string uh
using the split function what this will
do is it will split up the string at
every white space so it'll take this as
one part I'll take this part as another
part it will create an iterable with
each word as the um each iterable object
in that container so it's going to be a
list of words like python is one so on
and so forth and we're going to go one
by one so we're going to say forward in
line dot split now if this word is if it
exists in frequency table as a key then
what we're going to do is we're just
going to increase the count of the value
of that key by 1 but if it does not
exist then we're going to actually
create a key with the word as that
unique word and we're going to create
its value
um initialize its value to 1. so when we
execute this
now if we want to once you've done this
we can sort it by the count of the words
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a another Tuple called sorted
tuples where we're going to use the
Lambda function out here to sort the
um the dictionary in terms of its values
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take the key
uh the key being the Lambda item item
with index one index one is basically
the value
um so a particular key has a value so
the word python appears so many times
the per the word say scientist appears
so many times so we're gonna check which
words have the highest number of
occurrences and we're going to sort it
in a descending order so that that is
basically what the reverse is equal to
True does so when we're going to sort
this when we're going to use the sorted
function when we say reverse true uh it
tells the sortic function to sort this
dictionary
um this dictionary frequency table uh in
terms of value
by the the descending order so whichever
um word appears highest that would be
the first word in our sorted Tuple so
that's what we do in this slide and once
we execute this we're also going to
print so if you see the result of this
activity that we've done you can see
that the word machine
um appears six times learning appears
six times then python appears 510 and so
on and so forth so we've created a
sorted Tuple where the first object of
the Tuple
we've created a list of sorted tuples
where the first object of the two each
Tuple is the unique word and the num the
second one is the number of times it has
appeared in this
um particular example or this particular
string
so yeah this was uh what the first basic
project that we have tackled if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
hello everyone and welcome to another
video on Python Programming in this
video we will continue with what we
started in terms of our project number
one what we're going to do is
um we're going to tackle another
slightly complicated a question or a
situation we're going to try to arrive
at a solution so in this what we have is
some sort of a robot a moving robot
which moves on a Cartesian plane or two
coordinate plane
um is going to move uh in terms of up
down left and right okay and each each
time it moves up or down or left or
right it takes a certain number of steps
in that direction
um integral steps of course so what we
need to do is from a starting position
whatever its starting position is which
we're going to take as 0 comma 0 in this
example we're going to make it move to a
particular location with the commands up
down left and right followed by certain
steps
um and we're going to ask what we're
going to do is we're going to calculate
the distance between these two points
um am I going to calculate different
types of distances so you might be
introduced to New Concepts
um you know distance Concepts in this
video as well so what we're going to be
using for distance calculation is the
minkowski distance and that is
um we're going to take uh so the
minkowski distance between two variables
is basically the absolute difference
between these two variables of these two
points
um and we take it to the power of
something so if we want to say calculate
the minkowski distance with
um in terms the quadratic main Cloud
citizens with basically P2 so we are
going to do x i minus y i absolute
difference to the power 2 and then we're
going to take the second root of it
after summing each and every Point
um so when we take p is equal to 2 we we
say the minkowski distance behaves like
the euclidean distance and this is
probably one of the most common
distances uh in case you've done
um basic Cartesian geometry when you are
asked to find the distance between two
points on a plane we can also take the
absolute distance where we take p is
equal to one so in this case we're just
basically summing the absolute distances
between each point
um no roots no power is nothing
basically p is equal to one and we call
that the Manhattan distance so we're
going to take p is equal to 1 2 and 3 in
each case and we're going to find the
distance between two points uh based on
these
measures so
this is just a visual representation
this is basically the eagle in the
distance basically the estimate of the
value between these two points if um
since this is a two coordinate system
whereas the Manhattan distance would be
the absolute distance in terms of if we
go up and then we go right between these
two like save this first and this was
another Point
um so yeah
let's move on to the problem so what
we're in this in this particular example
we're going to start from the starting
position 0 and 0 on a on a graph and we
are going to give the commands of up
five down three left three and right two
so first of all what we want to do is
um we initialize the starting position
as 0 and 0 and we also just for the sake
of this example we initialize the end
position as 0 and 0. so what we're going
to do first of all is let's execute this
much now we have this list list of
tuples
um it's we're going to call this actions
and this is the actions that we're
performing so this the each Tuple
contains an action and the number of
steps in that direction so it contains
four actions up by five steps down by
three steps left by three steps right by
two steps so now we're going to iterate
over this each Tuple and we're going to
get the direction first of all in this
line
um for each step uh and we're going to
calculate the number of steps it takes
so for each action it's going to first
tell
um it's going to check what is the
direction which is done by this line and
we're going to find out the number of
steps in that direction which is stored
in this line so
once you've gotten this for each action
we have to update the end position right
so what happens is if you go up by a
particular direction so you are
basically changing the y y axis right
the the y-axis so we're going to change
end position and the first index which
is basically this part of the end
position coordinate point so we're going
to say if it's moving by up then we're
going to uh update by adding uh the
y-axis by the number of steps so
um and and if the direction is down
we're going to do the same thing for the
y axis but we're going to decrement it
similarly if we move left or right we're
moving the x axis right so we take n
position in the first index so we take
the x axis and if we're moving left it's
a negative uh it's a decrement and if
you're moving right it's an increment so
if there's any other like action like
any other action for example that was
given here we say pass so basically the
only valid actions that we can pass is
um up down left and right otherwise we
we just skip that particular action so
this is what the this particular Loop
will do it will update our final
position
so once we've done this
um if we if I execute this what will get
stored in the end position is basically
my end position so now that I have my
starting position and my end position
um just to show you what the end
Position will look like right now let's
just do this so if you see here after
I've moved up by five steps down by
three steps left by three steps and then
right by two steps my final end position
is minus one and two
um my start position on the other hand
was
as you remember it should be 0 and 0. it
is 0 and 0. so now we're going to find
the distance between 0 and 0 and -1 and
2. so we're going to first of all create
a function called minkowski distance
which which does the basic function of
just calculate the uh the difference
between the what do you say um the end
position x coordinate and the N position
y coordinate times uh or to the power of
a root and we're basically going to do
this operation that you saw here we're
going to do this and um we're going to
uh we're going to
use this root variable to specify to
like P is equal to one two or three like
what P value we want to take for this
minkowski distance so once you've done
this what this function will do is
basically store uh this much and it will
wait for us to uh it will basically wait
for us to give us a road so when we give
root 1 it will create these it will
check the distance between the end and
starting points
um with the p-value of one if you give
it two it will calculate euclidean
distance with p-value 2 similarly for
three and we can calculate for any Roots
so we're going to calculate for one two
and three routes and we're going to see
what values we get in each case
so when root is equal to 1 I print a
statement saying minkowski distance with
root 1 is something and then root 2 it's
something root 3 is something let's see
what results we get
so if you see here the minkowski
distance with root 1 is actually 1.0 but
the euclidean distance between these two
points is 2.23 whereas the uh the cubic
minkowski distance with basically the
with root 3 is 1.91 so you see these
three different uh distance measures for
the same distance between two points so
in this video you basically so in this
basically by doing this activity you
might must have you will learn how to um
basically how to iterate through loops
and perform these distance calculations
which you will find pretty handy in many
activities related to data science and
machine learning
so yeah this was on the project two
hello everyone and welcome to another
video on Python Programming in this
video we will be continuing tackling
different uh problems and problem cases
in terms of a project called project
three where we're going to be using
regular Expressions to validate whether
certain passwords that have been entered
do they match certain criterias or not
so let's look into our particular
question we have a website that requires
users to input username and password to
register now we have to write a program
to check the validity or passwords input
by the users now the criterias that the
passwords have to follow are that
there's at least one number between a
and z and this is at least one number
between is at least one letter between a
and z and one number between 0 and 9.
the third criteria is that uh there's at
least one letter between capital A and
capital Z so this first and third Point
basically is saying that there should be
one lowercase letter and there should be
one uppercase letter
um now they should be at least one
character from dollar sign hash or the
at simple it should have a minimum
length of 6 and the maximum length of
12. so when we whatever passwords that
we enter into our example they must be
comma separated so if we're going to
have an input they're going to ask us
for an input where we're going to have
to input the different passwords in a
comma separated way so let's look let's
look at how do we tackle this so for my
example I'm going to use these examples
in terms of these are my password
examples if you're going to check if
these are valid passwords or not so
let's copy this first of all and now
let's import the re which import re is
basically the regular expression module
now in this step is going to ask us to
input the passwords as you can see here
so I will just Ctrl V so since this is
comma separated what it will do is it
will split up each of these uh by the
comma and it will store them in a list
so it will take this as one password
this has another password this has
another password and this has another
password once I press enter
now if I want to check what's in list I
mean what's in items what I can do is
just check over here what's the items
it's a list of whatever passwords I had
entered uh each object is separately
treated now in this list now I'm going
to create a an empty list called value
first of all once I've done that I'm
going to move on to the next step
so once I've created my list called
value what I'm going to do is now I'm
going to search and I'm going to check
for each condition using regular
expressions for whatever criteria that
we have initially so if you see here
what I'm going to do is first iterate by
each item in this to check for each
password now my first check will be a
basic check for the length of the
password if it's lesser than 6 or
greater than 12 then our
our basically our password is illegal so
we can't be using this and we will just
continue and we won't check for anything
else but if it is within 6 and 12 the
length uh 6 and 12 then we can continue
with our check so we can do we'll do an
else statement for pass which basically
moves on to this next block
now once you've done this what we will
do is this this first statement what
this is going to do is it's going to do
an Ari dot search and re dot search as
you know is going to look for at least
one instance of um
a letter occurring between
um A and Z so this re dot search
followed by this now this is the regular
expression that we have passed and what
this does us is basically the square in
the square brackets we're looking for
anything between uh A and Z in terms of
small letters so if
um this is if this condition is not met
then again we continue and we leave this
particular search because one of our
criterias is not met all right but if it
is met then this if not statement will
not uh like we we won't enter this block
and we can move on to the next check so
now now we move to L if not now again
we're using if not statement so this is
basically checking for uh a negative
case so anytime one of these cases have
been met it basically means that our
password has been invalid because these
conditions are not being met so we're
trying to eliminate all uh conditions
all of these conditions so that we get a
valid password so again we move on to
the next statement which is the
basically going to do the search for
numbers once again if we find a case a
password without any numbers we continue
and we don't
check this password no more because we
already know it's a it's a an illegal
password now next check will be for
capital letters a to z and the next
check again will be for these particular
symbols the dollar the hash and the ad
one of these three symbols finally we
have a a search for
we're going to search for a white space
character so if we actually do find a
white space character in our password
that's an illegal password and we're not
going to continue checking for those
cases
so um so this is basically all our cases
as our lowercase letters numbers capital
letters these one of these three symbols
and the existence of a white space so
once you've done all these checks
um if if none of these have been passed
we move on to this else statement where
we just pass and what we can do is we
append the value we append the value to
uh we we append P to the uh the the list
called value so basically what happens
is
um just to go through it again if this
condition is not met uh and this
condition is not met this is not met
this is not met this is not met and if
this is also not met
um then we're fine so basically as long
as we have small letters as long as we
have a number as long as we have a
capital letter as long as we have one of
these three symbols and as long as we
don't have any uh White space characters
we can append e to this otherwise eyes
it will continue and it will break out
of this for Loop completely that's what
the continued thing the continue
statement at the end of each of these
blocks checks
um any time this condition is met uh
this if not condition is met then we
break through we break through this
whole for Loop and we don't append t to
the value but uh if we actually get to
this stage then what we can do is simply
append uh P to value now finally what we
are going to do is we're going to print
out all the valid
um all the valid passwords so just by a
quick look you can see here
um
this is a valid password right so let's
execute this and let's see uh what we
get if you see here we only get one
valid password and let's look at why
some of these did not turn out to be
valid so if you look here all of the
conditions are met it has a capital
letter it has a small letter it has at
least one number and it has one of the
symbols either dollar sign or the hash
sign or the AD Sign In this case we have
two white spaces one over here and one
over here so this is an illegal password
similarly in this case also we have an
illegal password because it begins with
a space in this case it's the same thing
we begin with a space and also it does
not have any of those uh symbols that we
were looking for the dollar or the hash
or the ad so again so these three are
illegal passwords and they do not get
appended to Value however this does get
appended to Value and that's why we get
the result for only one password which
is the only legal password and with that
we come to the end of this full course
tutorial I hope you guys enjoyed
watching the video do give it a thumbs
up comment your doubts below and our
experts will definitely answer them for
you thank you so much for being here
watch out for more videos from us until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
Simply thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here